In diesem Sommer werden zwei Bücher erscheinen von Frauen, die jeweils ihren Weg im Fußball gegangen sind und das trockts aller strukturellen Nachteile, die man als Frau im Fußballgeschäft noch hat. Wir wollen heute darüber sprechen mit Lena Cassel, die über die Regionalliga bei Fortuna Köln bis in die Primetime es geschafft hat. Ihr kennt sie ja vielleicht aus dem Mainzer Keller und dem Rasenfunk, aber ganz sicher auch von The Zone und Amazon Prime und wir wollen sprechen mit Kathrin Längert. Auch sie hatten wir, muss ich sagen, die Ehre auch schon hier im Rasenfunk zu haben. Sie hat es bis hin zum unter anderem DFB-Pokalsieg mit den Bayern-Frauen geschafft, aber hatte noch so viele interessante Stationen auch drum herum. Unter anderem war sie auch Torhüter-Trainerin vom Nationalteam der Frauen Saudi Arabiens. Also ihr könnt euch auf diese Folge wirklich freuen. Das Verbindende zwischen den beiden ist nicht nur die Liebe zum Fußball, sondern noch viel, viel mehr. Jetzt starten wir rein. Viel Spaß bei dieser Sendung.
Nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Dadurch, dass es eben die Bezahlung so gering ist, es waren 100 Euro im Monat, die ich ein bisschen als Fahrtgeld bekommen hab, hab ich halt immer noch einen Nebenjob dabei gehabt, neben dem Studium noch und dann noch Fußball. Und das war eben ein so immens hoher zeitlicher Aufwand.
Unseren anderen Damenmannschaften steht nur der Aschplatz Verfügung. Dabei hat Fortuna aber einen großen Rasenplatz, wo wir Frauen aber gar nicht trainieren dürfen. Der ist nur für die Profi-Mannschaft der Herren. Und deswegen müssen wir an dem System arbeiten und nicht an den Frauen, dass sich wirklich da auch etwas verändert.
Das Tribünengespräch.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und hallo und herzlich willkommen Lena Cassel, die beim Intro schon den Kopf geschüttelt hat. Hallo Lena, schön, dass du da bist.
Ja hallo, hallo, lieber Max. Hallo liebe Kathrin, hallo an euch genau. Also wir sind ja ein transparenter Podcast, so wie es sich gehört für den Rasenfunk. Und die kleinen Einspieler, die ihr gerade gehört habt, sprechen glaube ich nicht nur mir, sondern auch Kathrin aus der Seele. Also der Ton ist gesetzt für diese Folge. Ich freue mich sehr, hier zu sein.
Ja und dementsprechend auch hallo Kathrin, schön, dass du hier bist. Du hast auch schon genickt. Es ist so traurig, dass es so wieder reproduzierbar ist und dass einem alles so bekannt vorkommt und so weiter und so fort. Aber erstmal schön, dass du da bist.
Ja, ich freue mich auch sehr, dabei zu sein. Hallo an euch beide, hallo an alle da draußen. Mir geht es genau wie Lena. Ich habe erschrocken dazugehört und bin wirklich gespannt, wie viele furchtbare Beispiele wir heute noch sammeln können.
Ja, es ist, es tut mir leid, dass ich da so lachen muss, aber es ist wirklich so absurd. Also was wir jetzt gerade im Intro gehört haben, das war Isabella Mischke. Die hat bis zur zweiten Bundesliga beim FSV Gütersloh gespielt und dann eben ihre Karriere beendet, weil sie eben gesagt hat, unter anderem mit diesen 100 Euro im Monat, da kann ich nicht mal meine Fahrtkosten bezahlen. Dann haben wir noch eine Spielerin von Fortuna Köln gehört. Leider konnte ich den Namen nicht rausfinden. Es ist aus der Show von Caroline Kebekos, die eben über die Situation dort gesprochen hat. Und dann haben wir noch Tijan Ohneran gehört, die sich bei Phoenix zu dem ganzen Thema geäußert hat. Das war rund um die Zeit, in der Olaf Scholz damals gesagt hatte, es wäre nicht eine gleiche Bezahlung. Eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht bei den Prämien der DFB-Frauen. Da wurde ja über dieses Thema mal gesprochen. Ich will aber eigentlich gleich gar nicht sofort mit dem strukturellen Scheiß beginnen. Ich sage es jetzt mal so offen, sondern ich will eigentlich mit dem beginnen, was mir bei euren beiden Büchern passiert ist, als ich sie gelesen habe. Ich weiß nicht, ob das euch auch so geht, wenn ihr die Biografien von anderen Spielerinnen und Spielern lest. Man fühlt sich immer erinnert, wenn es ins Kindheitskapitel geht, an die eigene Fußballerinnerung. Dieses Mal hatte ich das so klar vor Augen, dass mir bewusst geworden ist über eure Bücher interessanterweise, was anscheinend meine schönste Fußballerinnerung ist. Die schönste Fußballerinnerung, das ist bei mir beim SV Unteralten-Barnheim. Ich stehe auf dem Fußballfeld interessanterweise alleine. Ich spiele aufs kleine Tor. Es ist warm, aber noch nicht zu warm. Wenn der Wind kommt, ist es immer ein bisschen fröstelnd. Deswegen muss man viel laufen. Ich habe meine allerersten Fußballschuhe an. Das waren Adidas, die wir billiger bekommen haben, weil wir in der Nähe von Herzog und Aurach gewohnt haben. Mit der eingestickten Signatur von Lothar Matthäus. Der Platz ist weich und viel zu lange schon nicht mehr gemäht. So war es immer beim SVU. Aber es war so, dass man, wenn man dann viel gerannt ist, konnte man dann immer den Matsch zwischen den Noppen herausholen. Und da habe ich mich immer so wahnsinnig cool gefühlt, wenn ich das gemacht habe. Ich habe stundenlang immer nur aufs leere Tor geschossen und habe nicht versucht, die Latte zu treffen. Das fand ich immer doof. Ich habe immer versucht, die Stange zu treffen im linken und rechten Toreck, so dass es dieses geile Geräusch gibt. Man hört es dann auch quasi, weil ansonsten hörst du nur irgendwie einen Traktor im Hintergrund. Das ist meine, glaube ich, schönste, mein Fußball-Senn-Moment, wenn ich an die besten Momente zurückdenke. Bei beiden Büchern hatte ich das vor Augen. Deshalb wollte ich jetzt fragen Lena, wenn du willst, dass du mal beginnst, was wäre denn dein Fußball-Senn-Moment?
Also erst mal ist es ja total schön. Ich habe schon einen Gänsehaut-Schauer auf meiner Haut gespürt, als du gesagt hast, das war halt so beim SVU. Das sind dann so die Begrifflichkeiten des Dorfes, die man dann so pflegt. Da gab es bei mir halt den Tuss, den Tuss-Schladern. Und jeder, der mal Fußball gespielt hat, kennt diese Kürzel. Also da fing es schon an mit diesem nostalgischen Gefühl. Und ich finde das total toll, was du sagst, weil ich glaube, manchmal, und das wird ja auch hier im Rasenfunk immer wieder besprochen, und das mag ich ja auch an dir und an diesem Format, dass wir durchaus auch kritische Geister sind, die immer mal wieder den Finger dahin richten an all die Sachen, die mittlerweile so wahnsinnig schlecht laufen in diesem Sport. Aber lass uns manchmal auch noch daran denken, wie denn eigentlich alles anfing. Und das war irgendwie auch ein Anliegen von mir, daran zu denken, was war denn das erste Gefühl? Was stand denn da am Anfang? Und am Anfang war da diese naive Begeisterung für einen Sport, wo ich plötzlich das Gefühl von Zugehörigkeit hatte und wo ich einen Ort hatte, wo ich hingehen kann. Und das war halt immer der Fußballplatz, weil es gab meistens nur zwei Ascheplätze auf dem Dorf und das war der Tennis und das war der Fußballplatz. Und ich glaube, meine allererste prägende Fußballerinnerung ist das Tor, was ich auch im Buch skizziere, weil ich war damals wirklich eine wahnsinnig untalentierte Spielerin. Ich habe mich eigentlich auch nicht sonderlich für diesen Sport interessiert, sondern vielmehr für das Drumherum. Ich fand das immer toll, dass da alle Leute immer um den Platz herum standen, dass viele Menschen da waren. Also es ging eher so um diese Zwischenmenschlichkeit, die mich begeistert hat, als der Sport an sich. Ich habe eher irgendwelche Sandbilder in die Asche gemalt, als wirklich mich mit diesem Sport zu beschäftigen. Und dann gab es eben diesen einen Nachmittag, wo ich in meiner Erinnerung mein allererstes Tor überhaupt erzielt habe. Es war ausverkauft, äh, ausverkauft. Also es waren sehr viele Menschen an diesem Samstagnachmittag da, denn es war Derbyzeit, SV Leuschheit gegen den Tuschladern. Ich spielte beim Tuschladern und ich habe da mein allererstes Tor erzielt. Ein Volley aus für mich naiven 200 Metern. Es waren vielleicht nur zwei, aber es war wahnsinnig weit entfernt in meiner Erinnerung. Und ich habe damals mein allererstes Geld mit dem Fußball verdient und auch mein einziges Geld, wohl bemerkt, denn für dieses Tor gab mir mein Opa 50 Euro. Und das hat sich wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr prägnant in meiner Erinnerung eingemasert, weil das so viel Geld war und weil ich so viel Anerkennung für dieses Tor bekommen habe. Und da hatte ich so ein leichtes Gefühl, das erste Mal bekommen, was der Fußball alles sein kann. Das war so mannigfaltig, dieses Gefühl. Und ja, das ist, glaube ich, mein Zen-Moment, den ich mit dem Fußballplatz und mit dem Fußball verbinde.
Kathrin, du hast schon angesetzt zu reden, hatte ich den Eindruck. Es sprudelt aus einem Reiß, wenn man das hört, wenn jemand anderes über seine Erfahrungen spricht. Was ist dein Zen-Moment?
Ich finde es auch total schön, dass die Erfahrungen halt so universell sind, über alle Altersklassen hinweg, über Geschlechts hinweg, auch über Herkunft hinweg. Ich musste schmunzeln, als du gesagt hast, beim SVU war der Rasen nicht gemäht, weil ich habe halt, bis ich 17 war, noch auf Asche gespielt. Bei uns gab es einfach nirgendwo einen Rasen, nicht mal einen Kunstrasen. Also selbst beim FC Duisburg haben wir in der Jugend noch auf Asche gespielt. Da weiß man dann immer ungefähr, wo die Herkunft geht. Mein Zen-Moment, den beschreibe ich auch im Buch, war, als ich mit meinem großen Bruder gespielt habe. Da war ich auf jeden Fall im Kindergartenalter, ich glaube drei oder vier. Und meine Oma hatte damals einen Gemüseladen in Gelsenkirchen Horst, auch so ein richtiger Arbeiterstadtteil. Und wir hatten deswegen einen Hof hinten, weil da das Lager war. Und alle Kinder aus der Nachbarschaft sind dann immer zu uns auf den Hof gekommen, weil da halt viel Platz war, weil man da relativ geschützt vor dem Straßenverkehr spielen konnte. Und zu diesem Hof gab es halt so eine lange Toreinfahrt, also wahrscheinlich ist die nur acht Meter lang oder so. Mir kam die ewig lang vor und halt groß und dunkel. Und die hatte so ein ganz schweres, gusseisernes Tor. Und immer, wenn halt einer gegen dieses Tor geschossen hat, hat es ganz laut gescheppert in diesem Hof und in der ganzen Straße. Und ja, ich durfte halt dann am Anfang immer nur ins Tor, weil ich halt die Kleinste war von allen. Und später durfte ich dann ins Tor, weil ich die Beste war im Tor von allen. Und meine Riesenaufgabe war halt immer zu verhindern, dass es so laut scheppert, damit wir weiterspielen dürfen, damit sich keiner von den Nachbarn beschwert. Und das war dann meine Mission, das laute Scheppern zu verhindern. Und ich habe es absolut geliebt.
Das ist so spannend, weil ich kann mich an so viele Dinge in meiner Kindheit gar nicht mehr erinnern, weil es, warum auch immer, alles sehr diffus und sehr weit weg ist. Aber ich habe so ganz starke Gefühle und kann mich genau an solche Szenen und das beschreibst du ja gerade Kathrin, so wahnsinnig detailliert. Du weißt alles noch so, wie das damals aussah bei diesem ja doch sehr prägenden Fußballmoment für dich. Und ich glaube, das liegt ja auch daran, dass da nicht nur auf so einer rationalen Ebene was passiert, sondern da sitzt ja auch so viel Gefühl. Und das ist ja eben auch das, was der Fußball dann als Kraft hat, dass da so viel Gefühl miteinander verbunden ist. Wenn du an dieses Tor denkst, was du verteidigen musstest, den Klang wahrscheinlich noch in deinem Ohr hast, wenn es dann doch zum Tor kam und so. Und ich glaube, wir können uns da so detailliert dran erinnern, weil da so viel Gefühl ist. Und das halt nicht nur irgendwo in unserem Groß- oder Kleinhörn verankert ist, sondern auch so viele in unserer Seele und in unserem Herzen. Und ich glaube, deshalb können wir uns alle so krass an diese Details erinnern. Und das ist so schön, weil einen das ja immer wieder auch in so ein, das hast du ja beschrieben, Max, als du unsere beiden Bücher gelesen hast, wieder in diese Zeit zurückversetzt und in dieses Gefühl der Sorglosigkeit und der Nostalgie. Und das ist ja eigentlich toll in so einer Welt, wie wir jetzt leben, wo es irgendwie schwer ist, noch richtig was zu fühlen, weil alles so schnell ist, mag ich das total gerne, nämlich auch Biografien zu lesen, weil es mich immer wieder in so ein Gefühl hineinversetzt und so ein Innehalten da ist und das ist total spannend gerade schon zu erfahren, wie detailliert unsere Erinnerungen sind. Es ist echt beeindruckend.
Ja und du hast vorhin schon ein ganz wichtiges Wort gesagt, finde ich, und das ist Zugehörigkeit. Und ich finde, das ist auch was, was in der Jetztzeit oft so ein bisschen verloren geht. Wir fühlen uns weniger zugehörig zu bestimmten Gruppen. Es gibt so eine, glaube ich, auch eine bestimmte Vereinsamung. Und als Kind ist es einfach so wahnsinnig wichtig, deine Gruppe zu finden und zu wissen, wo ist mein Platz. Und der Fußball hat einfach von Anfang an, finde ich, gibt der so eine unglaubliche Zugehörigkeit und ein Gefühl, was ich sehr mit diesen Erinnerungen auch verbinde, was ganz wichtig war und warum es, glaube ich, auch so prägend geblieben ist, ist Stolz. Ja, als Kind hat man einfach so ein paar Momente, wo man so durchströmt wird von diesem Stolz, was geschafft zu haben, was ganz besonders ist. Und das habe ich, das kann ich auch noch ganz lebhaft nachempfinden, wie einen diese Wärme durchströmt, wenn man eben, wie bei dir jetzt Lena, das so ein wichtiges Tor geschossen hat oder das erste Tor geschossen hat oder eben, wie bei mir zum ersten Mal so einen Unhaltbaren gehalten hat. Das vergisst man nie mehr.
Und das Interessante ist, dass wir hier schon die Verknüpfung haben zwischen dem Individuum und der Gesellschaft außenrum. Denn um Stolz zu bekommen, musst du auch etwas getan haben, von dem du dann den Stolz des Dorfes, in unseren Fällen, oder eines Stadtteils oder einer Straße bekommen kannst. Also wenn wir drei jetzt sehr talentierte Schauspielerinnen gewesen wären in unseren jungen Jahren, hätten wir wahrscheinlich eine andere Anerkennung bekommen und vielleicht auch nicht diesen klaren Stolz. Aber dadurch, dass wir eben im Fußball dann aktiv waren und da eben unsere kleinen Meilensteinchen erreicht haben im Kindesalter, das ist etwas, da wird dir, zumindest bei das in meiner Umgebung so, damit kannst du Eindruck schinden. Also ansonsten war ich der Pfarrerssohn, der gelesen hat und allein deshalb ein bisschen komisch war. Wir haben einfach ein bisschen ein anderes Leben geführt als die vielen anderen Kinder im Dorf. Aber dass ich gut Fußball spielen konnte, das war immer der Integrator und das hat mir auch später bei einem Umzug geholfen, im Dorf anzukommen. Und das zeigt ja aber auch schon, wie man sich eben auch als Kind nicht losmachen kann von der Umgebung, in der man lebt. Und das habt ihr ja auch dann logischerweise noch mal auf ganz andere Art und Weise erfahren, weil es eben einfach immer noch ungewöhnlicher ist, als Mädchen Fußball zu spielen und weil es immer etwas Besonderes ist. Also es wird auch immer markiert. Ihr konntet wahrscheinlich nie einfach nur Fußball spielen, außer in diesen ganz geschützten kleinen Gruppen, eben in der Hofeinfahrt mit den engsten Brüdern und Freunden oder eben im allerersten Verein. Deswegen wäre meine Frage, Lena, wenn du magst, dass du als Erster antworten. Wann war denn das zum ersten Mal, dass du das Gefühl hattest, es ist immer etwas Besonderes, dass du Fußball spielst als Mädchen? Und was hat das mit dir gemacht?
Also ich glaube, das erste Mal, dass ich das bemerkt habe, ist wirklich auch die Resonanz von außen, die ich dann mitbekommen habe, als ich nach diesem Wollitor, auch 200 Metern, gemerkt habe, okay, so schlecht bin ich eigentlich gar nicht. Ich interessiere mich dann doch mal ein bisschen mehr für diesen Sport, weil dieses Stolzgefühl, was Kathrin beschrieben hat, oder dieses Anerkennungsgefühl, und ich kriege was, wenn ich was tue und wenn ich was leiste, nämlich 50 Euro von meinem Opa, anerkennende Blicke von den Menschen von außen, da hat sich schon so eine Art von Ehrgeiz dann bei mir auch entwickelt. Und dann habe ich irgendwann natürlich bemerkt, dass es aufgefallen ist, wie ich spiele und dass ich ja für ein Mädchen sehr, sehr gut sei. Und da war der Referenzwert natürlich immer, wow, die spielt ja wie ein Junge. Also der Referenzwert für etwas Positives war natürlich etwas Männliches. Und ich habe das in der damaligen Zeit überhaupt gar nicht als komisch oder fragwürdig empfunden, sondern ich habe gedacht, cool, dann scheine ich ja wirklich gut zu sein, wenn ich spiele wie ein Junge, weil die Jungs sind ja alle gut und mega. Und jetzt im Verlauf der Jahre habe ich mich natürlich schon gefragt, warum der Referenzwert bei Leistungen immer der männliche ist. Warum ist das immer der Wert, an den wir uns orientieren? Und das ist das, was wir dann herausstellen. Und das habe ich aber erst im Verlauf der letzten Jahre so wirklich hinterfragt, weil mir das auch immer wieder jetzt passiert in meiner Tätigkeit als Sportjournalistin. Wow, für eine Frau hast du echt Ahnung. Man kann ja mit dir wirklich über fußballanalytische Themen sprechen. Oh, du weißt, was ein abkippender Sechser ist. Wahnsinn. Also ich werde auch oft eingeladen, weil ich eben eine Frau bin, die auch noch kompetent ist. Das ist dann dieser Zusatz so. Eine Frau, die auch noch kompetent ist. Wow, das gibt es ja jetzt nicht so häufig anscheinend. Das müssen wir mal in die erste Reihe stellen. Und das hat damals ja auch schon auf dem Fußballplatz angefangen, dass es etwas Besonderes war, dass ich Fußball gespielt habe und auch gut war. Also diesen Zusatz hat man irgendwie nicht so zusammenbekommen, dass da ein Mädchen ist, was gut ist. Sondern man hat eher so, und ich musste es so schmunzeln, dass Kathrin gesagt hat, dass sie ins Tor gekommen ist, weil sie die kleinste war. Bei uns, wenn überhaupt Mädchen, und ich war teilweise die Einzige, wenn überhaupt waren wir zwei. Und dann musste das andere Mädchen immer ins Tor, weil niemand ins Tor wollte. Das war der einzige Platz, der noch frei war. Und ich war eigentlich Stürmerin und ich musste immer als Rechtsverteidigerin spielen, weil niemand Rechtsverteidiger sein wollte. Also wir waren sozusagen da, um dann die Lücken aufzufüllen. Und das hat ja dann auch schon verdeutlicht, wie begrenzt unser Spielraum dann war, überhaupt stattzufinden. Da wurde dann eher, der war sehr begrenzt und der war dann eher so da, wo halt die Jungs keinen Bock drauf hatten, da durften wir dann reinstoßen. Also dass man gemerkt hat, dass man schon was anderes und dass man besonders ist, das wurde an allen Ecken und Enden deutlich.
Ich vermute Kathrin, dass es bei dir ähnliche, auch da wieder viele Parallelen gibt. Aber was würdest du sagen, wann ist dir das zum ersten Mal bewusst geworden, dass es ungewöhnlich ist, was du tust? Weil wenn man mit seinen Brüdern zusammen Fußball spielt, man spielt ja viele Spiele gemeinsam mit seinen Geschwistern, das kenne ich aus eigener Erfahrung, das ist ja noch alles völlig normal.
Absolut und das finde ich so spannend, dass es mir eigentlich ganz am Anfang überhaupt nicht bewusst war. Es war für mich das Normalste der Welt, so wie wir halt zusammen, weil sie nicht Memorie gespielt haben, haben wir halt auch zusammen Fußball gespielt. Alles war so eins. Und spätestens als ich in den Verein gegangen bin, dann war aber klar, okay, das ist anders. Also ich habe mir vorher nicht so Gedanken darüber gemacht, schon gar nicht im Kindergartenalter, wer ist Mädchen, wer ist Junge, was machen Mädchen, was machen Jungs. Aber ich bin ja dann relativ spät auch erst in den Verein gegangen, ich glaube, da war ich schon acht, und durfte dann ja mit meinem Bruder auch nicht mehr zusammen spielen, weil der in die Jugendhöhe eingeordnet wurde, rein alterstechnisch. Und da habe ich dann zum ersten Mal gemerkt, okay, ich bin das einzige Mädchen. Also ich dachte auch wirklich viele Jahre, keine anderen Mädchen spielen Fußball. Ich dachte, ich bin quasi weltweit das einzige Mädchen, weil ich nirgendwo andere Mädchen gesehen habe. Und dann war es natürlich so in meiner eigenen Peergroup wieder, in meiner Mannschaft, war ich relativ schnell akzeptiert. Aber auch nur, weil ich natürlich vielleicht auch Talent hatte. Ich glaube nicht, dass Mädchen, die jetzt schlechter gespielt haben als die Jungs in ihrem Team eine besonders gute Zeit hatten. Und sobald wir dann aber zum Spiel angetreten sind, war klar, ey, die haben ja ein Mädchen im Tor. Also es war wirklich, selbst für einen Achtjährigen, schon klar so der Lauf zum Anstoßpunkt ist wie so ein kleiner Spießrutenlauf. Ja, wenn du von der Kabine bis zum Anstoßpunkt musst, dann musst du schon durch alle Eltern durch, dann hörst du schon das Ganze getuscht, oh guck mal, da spielt ja ein Mädchen und die haben ein Mädchen. Dann streichst du dich mit den Mannschaften auf, dann hörst du die gegnerischen Jungs, ey, die haben ja ein Mädchen im Tor, aber heute schießen wir fünf Stück oder so, ne? Also das war quasi ab der Ehejugend war klar, ich bin Mädchen, das ist was Besonderes, aber nicht gut besonders.
Und es gab ja damals ja auch gar keine andere Möglichkeit in irgendeiner Form, in einem Verein zu partizipieren als Mädchen, weil es eben so wenige Mädchen gab, die überhaupt gespielt haben, gab es auch keine Mädchenmannschaften. Also da müssen wir ja auch nochmal darüber reden, dass die Struktur damals nochmal eine ganz andere war als jetzt. Gerade wenn man in einer dörflichen Struktur war, die nächste Frauenmannschaft in irgendeiner Form, wir reden nicht über Mädchenmannschaft, sondern die nächste Frauenmannschaft, die war teilweise über eine Stunde entfernt von uns damals, wo du überhaupt nur hättest mit anderen Frauen oder Mädchen spielen können. Also es gab keine andere Möglichkeit als in einer Jungsmannschaft Fußball zu spielen und deshalb ist es natürlich auch aufgefallen, weil es eben wenig Mädchen gab und sie eben nur da in diesem Platz, in der nominelle Jungsmannschaft teilnehmen durften. Also es war auch strukturell neu und anders und besonders, weil es ja auch keine andere Möglichkeit gab für Mädchen Fußball zu spielen damals. Also ich glaube, es ist wirklich ein strukturelles Thema auch gewesen. Also dass es dadurch eben besonders war.
Ja und auch eine Frage der Sichtbarkeit. Ich meine, ich war Mitte der 90er, acht Jahre alt und da waren die deutschen Frauen schon viermal Europameisterin und ich wusste nicht, dass es eine Frauen-Nationalmannschaft gibt. Ich kannte keine einzige Nationalspielerin, ich wusste auch nicht, dass es eine Bundesliga gibt. Es gab keinen Frauenfußball im Fernsehen. Ich habe wirklich viel Sport auch damals schon geguckt mit meiner Mutter, mit meiner Oma. Ich kannte Katja Seitzinger und Franzi van Almzig und Steffi Graf. Ich wusste also, es gibt Frauen, die Sportlerinnen sind und dass man da auch erfolgreich sein kann. Aber ich hatte gar keine Ahnung, dass es irgendwo einen Spielbetrieb für Frauen gibt, weil das nirgendwo sichtbar war für mich.
Da kann ich vielleicht noch eigene Biografie ergänzen. Ich habe ja bekanntermaßen zwei Zwillingsmädchen und irgendwie sind die in diesem Haushalt auch mit Fußball in Berührung gekommen. Ich weiß nicht, wie das passieren konnte. Und inzwischen ist es aber so, also bei uns läuft ja hin und wieder dann doch mal ein Fußballspiel. Oder ich sage den Mädels heute Abend, spielen zum Beispiel die Bayern, weil halt hier in München ist es natürlich ein großes Thema, in der Grundschule oder im Gymnasium jetzt. Sie konnten auch in der Grundschule immer damit punkten, dass sie wussten, was so groß los ist. Aber inzwischen ist die Frage nur noch Männer oder Frauen. Und wenn ich sage Männer, dann überhaupt gar kein Interesse mehr. Interessiert sie wirklich? Also da gucken sie vielleicht mal kurz hin. Und am Anfang fand ich das komisch, weil ich mir gedacht habe, in der Grundschule wart ihr noch so stolz drauf, wenn ihr mit den Jungs diskutieren könnt über Harry Kane und so weiter und so fort und Damal Moziala und habt dafür Anerkennung bekommen. Da waren sie auch wahnsinnig stolz. Und jetzt aber ist ihnen das nicht mehr wichtig. Und eigentlich ist es ja aber logisch, wenn man dann weiterdenkt, ja na klar. Die Identifizierung ist natürlich mit den Frauen eine ganz andere als mit den Männern. Und das hat aber halt wirklich genau mit dem zu tun, was ihr sagt. Man muss es sehen. Es muss sichtbar sein. Und dann hat man auch die Möglichkeit, sich da selbst reinzuträumen oder auch einfach nur als Zusehende zu genießen. Also die Tage, an denen sie dachten, sie werden selbst Profi-Spielerinnen, da habe ich den Eindruck, die sind schon wieder vorbei. Das war nur eine ganz kurze Phase. Und das ist ja auch völlig gut so eigentlich. Aber wenn wir jetzt darüber sprechen, es gab quasi damals nicht die Strukturen, um in reine Mädchenmannschaften zum Beispiel zu spielen. Die Situation hat sich ja leider gar nicht so sehr verbessert. Im Gegenteil, die Vereine sterben wie die Fliegen. So muss man es eigentlich verdeutlichen. Kathrin, du hast es ja auch in deinem Buch auch noch mal rausgearbeitet. Was müsste sich denn deiner Meinung nach verändern, damit der Einstieg für Mädchen in Fußball ein organischere werden könnte und sie vielleicht erstmal, weil es wäre doch eigentlich schön, wenn Kinder erstmal einfach nur Fußball spielen dürften und nicht immer gleich schon in dieser Sonderbeobachtung spielen müssten.
Ja, es müsste natürlich einfach viel, viel breiter aufgestellt sein. Also es gibt ja keine entspannte Situation, eben weil es so wenig Teams gibt, weil die Mädchen dann von Anfang an ein Problem der Zugehörigkeit haben. Wo finde ich die nächste Mannschaft? Wenn sie bei den Jungs integriert werden, dann immer noch leider Probleme haben, dort auch akzeptiert zu werden. Also ich habe immer noch Bekannte, die mich anrufen und fragen, ich wohne in Hürth, kennst du einen Mädchenverein in der Nähe? Meine Tochter spielt bei den Jungs, die wird nie angespielt, der Trainer setzt sie nicht ein. Also die auch immer noch ein feindseliges Umfeld vorfinden. Ich glaube, dass der Schulfußball ein riesengroßer Schlüssel wäre. Ich wünsche mir einfach, wir würden über die Grundschulen, da gibt es ein ganz schönes Projekt, was ich hier in Essen auch mal anstoßen wollte. Von Footballo Girls heißen die einfach, Grundschul-AGs zu haben, wo Mädchen einfach ganz niedrigschwellig ein bisschen mit Fußball in Kontakt kommen können. Eben separat von den Jungs, die dann teilweise schon viele Jahre spielen und vielleicht auch schon einen Vorsprung haben, der es den Mädchen dann irgendwie schwer macht, direkt Freude daran zu finden. Aber das Problem haben wir hier in Essen dann eben auch gehabt. Du musst auch die Vereine drumrum finden, die die Mädchen dann aufnehmen, wenn die eben die Grundschule verlassen oder wenn die über die Schule hinaus spielen wollen. Wir brauchen einfach viel, viel, viel mehr Mädchenmannschaften. Und dafür muss es, glaube ich, Anreize bei den Vereinen geben. Denn viele Vereine sind sowieso schon an der maximalen Kapazität, was die Platzzeiten betrifft. Und viele Vereine haben jetzt schon Schwierigkeiten, unabhängig von Spielklasse, Jungs oder Mädchen, Trainer zu finden und Trainerinnen, die nebenberuflich überhaupt noch ehrenamtlich arbeiten können. Und ich denke, es ist ein ganz großes Basisproblem im Fußball, dass sich bei den Mädchen, eben weil sie eine besonders vulnerable Gruppe sind, noch mal deutlich stärker zeigt als bei den Jungs.
Sieh ich ähnlich. Und ich glaube schon auch, dass der erste Anreiz für Mädchen, dass sie in einen Verein gehen, dass sie Fußball spielen wollen, natürlich erst mal geschaffen werden muss, dass sie da auch die Option haben, in einer Mädchenmannschaft zu spielen. Weil ich glaube, die Hürde, da reden wir auch nicht nur im Jugendlichen oder im Kinderalter über Stolz, sondern auch viel über Scham. Auch das ist ja ein total prägendes Gefühl in der Kindheit. Wir werden das alle kennen, dass man sich wahnsinnig schämt, relativ schnell und erst recht dann, wenn man eben da Zugehörigkeitsprobleme hat, wenn man eben nur mit Jungs spielt. Ich glaube, die Hürde, dann in einen Verein zu gehen, ist immens. Und wie schaffen wir das? Ich glaube schon, dass es ein infrastrukturelles Thema ist, dass wir natürlich mehr Investitionen in die Basis brauchen, dass wir das Ganze breiter streuen sollten, dass es Ausbildung für Trainerinnen gibt, dass es dann aber auch Plätze für Mädchen gibt, dass sie auch unter guten Bedingungen Fußball spielen können und nicht irgendwie, so wie wir damals mit dem Sport sozialisiert worden sind, also eigentlich immer auf dem Ascheplatz und ohne Trikots und dann auch nur die Trikots, die nicht passen und eigentlich die abgewanzten von den Jungs. Das ist ja so total niedrigschwellig, aber ich glaube schon, dass das Anreize schaffen kann. Cool, ich habe einen Trainingsanzug, ich habe ein passendes Trikot, ich habe meine eigene Nummer. Das schafft wirklich Anreize für junge Kinder generell in einen Verein zu gehen und in eine Mannschaft zu gehen. Wir wissen natürlich schon, dass der DFB einfach kein Geld hat, um so eine breite Investition zu tätigen in die Basis. Ich glaube, das wäre schon nötig, um da wirklich eine Infrastruktur aufzubauen, dass gerade Mädchen auch die ähnlichen Startvoraussetzungen haben wie Jungs. Und das ist jetzt so das, wie bringen wir eigentlich so Hobbyfußballmannschaften für Mädchen wieder so in die Gesellschaft. Aber das ist ja auch ein total wichtiger Nährboden, um die Spitze gesunden zu lassen im Fußball der Frauen. Weil wenn du gute Infrastruktur für die Basis schaffst, dann kommen mehr Mädchen zum Fußballspielen. Wenn du mehr Mädchen hast, unter guten infrastrukturellen Bedingungen, schaffst du auch, sage ich mal, mehr Konkurrenzkampf und vielleicht auch die Ambition, ein bisschen höher spielen zu wollen. Und dann hast du natürlich auch mehr Mädchen, die richtig gut Fußball spielen können und die auch mehr wollen. Und dann, glaube ich, hast du auch mehr Konkurrenzkampf auf der obersten Ebene. Und dann wird auch die erste und die zweite Bundesliga attraktiver, weil dann können wir auch wirklich ernsthaft über Aufstockungen reden, weil es eben mehr Mädchen, mehr Frauen gibt, die Fußball spielen. Also das ist schon so ein Kreis, der sich, also wenn du die Basis gesunden lässt, würdest du in ein paar Jahren, vielleicht Jahrzehnten, auch oben ankommen. Und dann können wir irgendwann eventuell auch mal über gleiche Bezahlung und so weiter und so fort sprechen. Aber ich glaube, der Startpunkt ist genau das, worüber wir reden. Wie schaffen wir Anreize, dass mehr Mädchen Bock haben auf Fußball spielen? Und dann können wir irgendwann nämlich auch darüber reden, wie schaffen wir es, dass wir endlich über gleiche Bezahlung und faire Bezahlung von Frauen im Profifußball sprechen. Ich glaube, das hat alles miteinander zu tun. Das ist ein Zyklus, den man an der Basis ansetzen muss und nicht vom Ende her denken muss, dass wir die ganze Zeit über Equal Pay reden. Ich glaube, da müssen wir erst mal zehn Schritte zurück. Das ist genau das Gespräch, was wir gerade führen. Wie schaffen wir auf so einer ganz banalen Ebene Anreize, damit Mädchen erst mal nur Bock haben, Fußball zu spielen? Und im zweiten Schritt haben sie dann vielleicht Bock, Profi zu werden. Aber erst mal müssen sie Bock haben, in der Mannschaft zu gehen.
Das ist total spannend, dass du das sagst. Genau das beschreibe ich im Buch, dass die Entwicklung eigentlich von unten nach oben kommen muss. Dass wir viel über die Entwicklung der Spitze reden. Das hat auch eine Berechtigung, zu sagen, warum ist die Prämie für ein WM-Sieg der Frauen geringer als bei den Männern? Weil Weltmeister ist Weltmeister. Aber wenn wir uns langfristig entwickeln und verbessern wollen, dann braucht es eben die Basis. Und dann braucht es auch eine ganz andere Akzeptanz an der Basis. Und was wir halt auch vergessen, ist, wenn Mädchenfußball so was selektives ist, wo es ein Team immer nur in einer Stunde Entfernung Fahrtzeit gibt, dann ist es auch wahnsinnig selektiv. Und ich glaube, wir verlieren einfach so viele Gruppen, nämlich vor allem Mädchen mit Migrationsgeschichte und aus sozial benachteiligten Familien, weil denen genau dieser Zugang fehlt. Also ich habe ja jetzt auch fünf Jahre in der Jugend der SGS Essen gearbeitet und wir haben einfach wahnsinnig, es ist der Frauenfußball ist immer noch sehr weiß, sehr akademisch, weil die halt die Eltern haben, die sie fahren können, die die Zeit haben am Nachmittag, die ein Auto haben. Wenn wir hier in Essen ein Mädchenfußballcamp machen und du verteilst dafür Flyer, dann ist es schon an einer Kollegin passiert, dass sie von einer Schülerin gefragt wurde, ja kommst du mich dann abholen? Weil man halt auch in der Großstadt schon anderthalb Stunden dann mit dem Bus unterwegs ist und wer lässt denn seine elfjährige Tochter irgendwie abends anderthalb Stunden dann irgendwie zum Training hinfahren und zurück? Also das heißt, ich glaube, es gibt so viele Gruppen und so viele talentierte Mädchen, die wir gar nicht finden, die wir noch nie gesehen haben und die fehlen uns in der Spitze. Ja, und die fehlen uns aber auch in der Breite, weil wie Lena schon sagt, wir brauchen auch in den einzelnen Spielklassen natürlich mehr Konkurrenz, mehr Teams. Kann nicht sein, dass Teams zwangsabsteigen müssen, weil ihnen irgendwie Spielerinnen fehlen oder weil sie dann den einzigen Sponsor verloren haben. Also ich glaube, dass wir eben vergessen, dass auch eine Frage der sozialen Gerechtigkeit ist zu sagen. Mädchen finden genauso in ihrer Nachbarschaft Angebote für Sport, wie es für Jungen selbstverständlich ist.
Und das eigentlich absurde ist ja, das ist ein No-Brainer. Also wenn ich jetzt die Entscheidung treffen müsste, bekommt keine Ahnung, Jule Brandt 5 Millionen Euro als Prämie oder stecke ich 5 Millionen Euro in den Breitensport? Dann tut es mir sehr leid für Jule Brandt. Das ist auch überhaupt nicht persönlich gemeint. Aber natürlich gehe ich aus gesellschaftlichen Gründen in den Breitensport. Denn für die gesamte Gesellschaft ist es gut, wenn sich Kinder bewegen, wenn Jugendliche Lust auf Sport haben und wenn man auch Sport als etwas Positives erfährt. Der Sportunterricht in Deutschland ist schon nicht so gestaltet, dass das unbedingt möglich ist. Dann können wir es ja vielleicht außerhalb des Sportunterrichts hinbekommen. Das heißt eigentlich ist das wirklich eine Sache. Da müsste es eine Zustimmungsquote von 100 Prozent geben. Und ich vermute auch, ich meine Kathrin, du hast ja unter anderem mit dem DFB auch über solche Themen gesprochen. Da wird dann immer genickt und wird gesagt, ja. Und dann kommt aber das Aber. Und das Aber ist ganz mannigfaltig ausformuliert. Aber irgendwann kommst du immer auf den Punkt Geld. Und angeblich ist ja kein Geld da. Wenn man sich anguckt, wie viel Geld man in den Campus stecken konnte und wie viel Geld der DFB jährlich einnimmt, dann mag man das immer nicht sogar ganz glauben. Das Geld ist halt nur nicht da, worüber gerade gesprochen wird. Woran würdest du denn sagen, scheitert es, dass selbst diese basalen Dinge, die eigentlich ja unwidersprochen nur positiv wären, nicht wirklich angegangen werden?
Na ja, wenn man sich lang genug mit der Datenlage beschäftigt, finde ich, kommt man ja irgendwann nicht um hin zu denken. Es fehlt ein gewisser politischer Wille, das Ganze umzustrukturieren. Ich bin mir durchaus darüber bewusst, dass wir von einem riesen Verband sprechen und große Organisationen sind halt immer auch sehr schwere Tanker. Da was zu bewegen, fällt halt auch schwer. Aber ich habe manchmal den Eindruck, man hat sich da so eingerichtet über die Jahrzehnte in seinen Ausschüssen und in den Landesverbänden und bis die sich mal alle getroffen haben. Und ich meine, da hängt ja auch viel Macht dran für viele Personen. Die müssen dann nur mal sagen, meistens alte weiße Männer sind, ist nun mal so. Und denen auch ein bestimmtes Bewusstsein, glaube ich, dafür fehlt. Ich unterstelle gar nicht immer absicht, dass da jetzt jemand denkt, ne, Frauen, denen gebe ich nichts, sondern dass denen wirklich nicht klar ist, oft wie die Lage an der Basis aussieht. Ja, war mir auch nicht klar, weil ich im Leistungssport sozialisiert wurde. Ich habe ganz viel erst im Nachhinein erfahren, als ich angefangen habe, selber Trainerlehrgänge zu besuchen und halt auch selber Trainerlehrgänge zu leiten, weil ich dann halt mit Menschen aus dem Amateurfußball in Kontakt gekommen bin. Und dann hörst du eben, wo der Schuh so ein bisschen drückt. Dann beschäftigt man sich mal eben damit, wie viele Vereine sich inzwischen Plätze teilen müssen, dass es dazu zu Verdrängungskämpfen kommt, dass wegen der gestiegenen Arbeitszeiten viele keine Zeit mehr haben, ihre Jugendmannschaften nebenbei noch zu trainieren. Das so kleine Hüren. Die Trainer, die Reform der Trainerlehrgänge gehen meiner Meinung nach ein bisschen nach hinten los. Die gehen am Bedürfnis der Basis vorbei. Also es gibt einfach viel, glaube ich, Unkenntnis beim DFB. Und deswegen würde ich mir eigentlich wünschen, dass man sich da auch mal die Mühe macht, Geld in die Hand zu nehmen, in die Peripherie reinzureichen. Also wirklich auch mal über Town Halls, über wissenschaftliche Studien wirklich zu schauen, was sind die Bedarfe von kleinen Vereinen in den Städten, auf dem Land. Da gibt es ja noch mal Unterschiede für Jungs, für Mädchen. Es gibt bestimmten Dutzend Universitäten, die sich die Finger lecken würden, wenn die mal eine große Zusammenarbeit, eine Kooperation beim DFB haben dürften, um solche Dinge zu erforschen. Aber solange sich halt fünf Typen mit 60 in irgendeinem Hinterzimmer in Frankfurt treffen und den Jugendfußball reformieren wollen, habe ich das Gefühl, werden wir nicht am ganz großen Rad drehen.
Also der Frauenfußball hat definitiv keine Lobby beim DFB. Wir erinnern uns, im Jahr 2024 ist Nia Künzer die erste Sportdirektorin Frauenfußball beim DFB jemals geworden. Das heißt, man fängt an, zumindest in kleinen Babyschritten, mal darüber nachzudenken, dass es sinnvoll wäre, dass es sich eben nicht fünf mittelalte weiße Männer in einem Hinterzimmer darüber unterhalten, was können wir denn jetzt hier mit dem Frauenfußball machen, wir müssen da jetzt, aber da ist ja jetzt gerade der Zeitgeist, wir müssen jetzt mal irgendwas machen. So, sondern da macht es natürlich durchaus Sinn, Menschen mit diesem Thema zu betrauen, die sich auskennen, die einen Willen haben, Dinge zu verändern, die Dinge vorantreiben möchten. Und das wird auch nicht nur über die Person Nia Künzer funktionieren, sondern ich glaube, du brauchst direkt ein eigenständiges Organigramm. Das heißt, du brauchst auch Menschen, die sich mit Entwicklung Frauenfußball beschäftigen. Das ist dann ein Department. Dann Entwicklung Mädchenfußball, das ist ein Department. Also du brauchst Köpfe, die wirklich eigenständig in einem eigenständigen Organigramm vom DFB sich nur mit dem Strang Mädchen- und Frauenfußball beschäftigen. Und da sind wir einfach noch lange nicht. Der Frauenfußball wird immer als Beifang des Männerfußballs mitverhandelt. Das ist bei der Vermarktung so. Das ist aber natürlich auch bei infrastrukturellen Dingen so, dass man dann sagt, ach ja, und was machen wir mit dem Frauenfußball? Das wird dann noch so als Punkt 6,1 bei einem 8-Stunden-Tag noch mal kurz mitverhandelt und mitbesprochen. So wird das nicht funktionieren. So ist es Alibi, so ist es Ausrede, so ist es aber nicht wirklich gewollt. Und ich glaube, da muss sich in der Struktur des DFB fundamental etwas verändern. Ich war schon sehr erstaunt, dass sie überhaupt mit Nia Künzer jetzt mal so eine Position geschaffen haben. Das ist für mich der Anfang, das ist noch lange nicht das Ende. Darunter soll es fünf, sechs, sieben Stränge geben, wo der Frauenfußball besprochen werden kann. Erst dann können wir wirklich an der Basis was ändern und erst dann können wir diesen No-Brainern, wie du ihn sagst, Marx, bin ich komplett bei dir, endlich ins Rollen bringen. Weil die Faktenlage ist ja klar. Und wir wissen doch alle, wo die Probleme liegen. Ich verstehe nicht, warum man sie nicht endlich anpackt. Weil dann können wir uns auch endlich diese ganzen Diskussionsrunden, die man dann einmal im Jahr führt, wenn es dann um die Frauen-EM geht, wo dann noch mal kurz die große Frage gestellt wird immer, was ist denn gerade der Status Quo des Frauenfußballs? Das wird jetzt übrigens wieder im Juli passieren, während der Frauen-EM. Macht euch schon mal gefasst. Und dann ist die Frauen-EM vorbei, dann beginnt August, dann ist die Männerbundesliga wieder da. Und dann reden wir irgendwann beim nächsten Turnier noch mal darüber. Das muss viel natürlicher und wirklich über die große Ereignisse hinaus passieren, dass wir das im Diskurs besprechen.
Ich finde, du hast einen total wichtigen Punkt, weil es wirklich spannend ist, dass die Frauenabteilung ganz oft bei der männlichen Jugend quasi im Verein eingesiedelt ist. Also bei Bayern zum Beispiel saß unsere Managerin Karin Danner zusammen mit Wolfgang Gremler, der die Jugend organisiert hat. Und die sind auch am Campus zusammen mit den Jugendmannschaften vom FC Bayern. Und es ist bei ganz vielen Vereinen so, dass die Frauen quasi behandelt werden wie kleine Männer. Ja, und da dann bei den kleinen Männern auch mittrainieren auf der Anlage und das Stadion von den kleinen Männern nutzen und die Trainingsplätze sich mit den kleinen Männern teilen. Dann kommt erst die U10, dann kommt die U12 und dann kommt die U14 und dann dürfen irgendwann mal die Frauen auf den Platz. Also wir sind da wirklich, wir werden nicht wie eine eigene, gleichberechtigte, wertvolle Abteilung behandelt, sondern wie ja so die kleinen Aliens, die noch irgendwo mit untergebracht werden müssen. Und ich finde es ehrlicherweise auch ein bisschen peinlich, dass Andreas Rettig, der ja nochmal ein Künstlers Vorgesetzter ist, bei seinem Amtsantritt auch gesagt hat, dass er bisher eher wenig Ahnung von Frauenfußball hat und deswegen auch froh ist, dass er den NIA da jetzt an seiner Seite hat. Oder dass er beim Trainerkongress letztes Jahr war es, glaube ich, beim Trainerinnenkongress, wo es auch darum ging, wie kann man mehr Frauen da in diesen Job bekommen, gesagt hat, er glaubt vielleicht bräuchten die einfach mehr Mut, sich zu bewerben. Wo ich mir denke, Mut ist nicht so das Problem. Ich könnte dir 20 andere Gründe nennen, unter anderem, dass man nirgendwo einen Job bekommt, wo Junge- und Männerfußball gespielt wird und sich die Investition deswegen nicht lohnt. Oder dass die Lehrgänge so teuer sind, dass ich die selbst als ehemalige Bundesligaspielerin nicht bezahlen kann. Also da ist so viel Unwissenheit selbst an ganz entscheidenden Stellen. Und ich finde auch so traurig, dass man das auch noch so sagen und leben darf. Also man stelle sich vor, der hätte jetzt gesagt, mit Männer Nationalmannschaft habe ich mich nicht so beschäftigt. Ich habe ja bei den Vereinen gearbeitet. Ja, also es wäre undenkbar. Aber es ist völlig akzeptiert und okay im Fußball, wenn man sich mit Frauen nur beschäftigt, keine Ahnung hat. Übrigens auch in den Medien. Also es ist ja schon ein Wunder, wenn die die Namen alle richtig aussprechen können, wenn dann mal wieder die Turniere anstehen. Genau wie Lena sagt. So dumm sind dann leider auch oft die Fragen. Und man darf dann auch nicht vergessen, dass dann auch Verbände wie die UEFA oder die FIFA ja auch noch ihr Übriges tun. Weil während die Frauen-EM im Juni stattfindet, wurde noch mal eben diese Club-WM da reingelegt, die niemand braucht, die wirklich reine Geldmacherei ist und die dann wieder das bisschen Aufmerksamkeit, dieses kleine Fenster, was man uns gönnt, das wieder limitiert und da wieder ein Stück vom Kuchen abschneidet.
Auf der anderen Seite muss ich sagen, die Blaupause für mich, wo der Männerfußball krankt und wo der Fußball der Frauen eventuell auch der Gegenentwurf dazu sein kann, wenn wir über Zielgruppen reden, wenn wir über Aufmerksamkeit reden, war für mich dann trotzdem das Jahr 2022. Das war die WM in Katar, wo sehr viele Menschen gesagt haben und sehr viele Fußballfans gesagt haben, ne, da mache ich nicht mehr mit. Das ist genau das Abziehbild, wo der Männerfußball krankt. Und ich schaue mir die Frauenfußball-EM an und wir wissen, wir haben das meistgesehene TV-Event des Jahres 2022 im EM-Finale gehabt, der Frauen. Und ich hoffe so ein bisschen, dass die FIFA Club-WM jetzt und die Frauen-EM jetzt wieder so ein Beispiel aufmachen, wo man sagt, hey, eventuell wende ich mich noch der gesunderen Variante des Fußballs zu und das finde ich bei der Frauen-EM und das finde ich ganz sicherlich nicht bei der FIFA Club-WM der Männer. Also ich finde schon, dass das auch immer eine gute Chance ist, nicht nur, dass man da das Licht genommen bekommt, sondern eher, dass der Scheinwerfer noch ein bisschen heller gestellt werden kann bei den Frauen, wenn man nämlich auf der anderen Seite dann ein Parallel-Turnier hat, wo man denkt, das braucht keiner, das ist nur aufgrund des Kapitals findet dieses Turnier statt. Es wird auch nicht gut anzusehen sein, weil die Topspieler alle verletzt sind oder nicht mitreisen werden. Ich schaue mir dann, weil ich Bock auf Fußball habe, nämlich den Fußball der Frauen an und das kann auch nur große Chance sein.
Und ich glaube, da hast du einen ganz wichtigen Punkt, weil das Publikum sieht es auf jeden Fall so. Und ich glaube einfach, dass die Fußballfans und die Gesellschaft da schon deutlich weiter sind als die Vereine und der Verband selbst. Ich habe manchmal den Eindruck, oder der DFB hat da eigentlich auch eine ganz gute Geschichte drin, konservativer zu sein als der Konsens der Gesellschaft. Weil ich finde, weil es sind dann wieder diese Kleinigkeiten, aber es ist ein Zeichen, wenn Herr Dresen dann zur Präsentation des Club-WM-Pokals geht und nicht zum Halbfinale der Bayern Frauen am Campus. Ja, das ist einfach ein Zeichen, wo ich sage, wo liegen jetzt hier meine Prioritäten im Verein? Wo ist die Wertschätzung? Oder dass nach der WM 22 eben diese Expertenkommission einberufen wird und es war eine Expertenkommission. Nur Männer, keine Frau. Als wüssten, als hätte keine Frau Ahnung davon, was dem deutschen Fußball gut tun würde, unabhängig davon, ob es die Männer oder die Frauen betrifft. Oder dass dann eine Konsequenz der WM war, zu sagen, wir spielen wieder mit dieser dämlichen Spielführerbinde in schwarz-rot-gold, wo Spielführer draufsteht. Als hätte jetzt diese Regenbogenbinde dafür gesorgt, dass sie aus dem Turnier ausscheiden. Also es sind so Kleinigkeiten, wo ich mir denke, Leute, da sind wir schon weiter. Und gerade deswegen findet der Frauenfußball sein Publikum und wird in der Zukunft noch viel mehr Leute anziehen, weil die sich genau mit diesen Dingen im Fußballbusiness nicht mehr identifizieren können und da auch eigentlich keine Lust mehr drauf haben.
Und gleichzeitig ist es so schön, es ist, dass wir immer wieder Quotenerfolge haben für Spiele von Frauen. Mir wieder strebt es, ehrlich gesagt, immer so ein bisschen, dass das schon wieder der Gradmesser des Erfolgs sein soll. Weil es ist natürlich ein wichtiger Indikator und das ist auch schön zu sehen. Aber eigentlich muss es ja gar nicht darum gehen. Eigentlich geht es doch darum, dass Fußball ein schönes Spiel ist. Und es sollte eigentlich viel eher darum gehen, um die Frage, warum wird eigentlich immer so getan, als ob nur Männerfußball ein gutes Spiel sei. Und warum ist es so akzeptiert? Ich meine Lena, wir beide arbeiten in der Branche im Sportjournalismus. Es ist völlig akzeptiert, als Sportjournalist, ich muss nicht gendern, zu sagen, für Frauenfußball interessiere ich mich nicht. Habe ich noch nie ein Spiel gesehen. Das ist, weiß ich gerade gar nicht, was die machen. Spielen die gerade Nations League? Ich habe jetzt gerade vor dem Champions-League-Spiel Bayern gegen Inter, als ja vorher noch das Nations-League-Spiel der Frauen lief, dass ich logischerweise geguckt habe, da hat mir das noch ein bekannterer TV-Mensch gesagt. Also ich meine, ich wusste ja immerhin, dass die Nations League spielen. Das ist doch schon mal gut, hat er zu mir gesagt. Und ich so, nee, ehrlich gesagt, finde ich das traurig, dass du das auch gar nicht gucken willst. Und dann war das Zitat, jedes Interesse von mir für Frauenfußball wäre gehorchelt, deshalb lasse ich es ganz. Und das ist ein ansonsten sehr geschätzter Kollege, auch von mir sehr geschätzt. Aber das ist doch ein völlig irrer Satz, dass man sich Sport- und Fußballjournalist nennen darf, obwohl man die eine Hälfte dieses Sports einfach komplett ignoriert. Und deswegen ging es mir gar nicht nur um die Reichweite bei solchen Dingen. Und ich vermute Lena, dass du, also off-air könntest du wahnsinnig viele Geschichten erzählen. Vielleicht kannst du auch on-air auch deine eigenen Erfahrungen damit teilen. Wir springen jetzt schon ein bisschen, aber du hast es ja dann irgendwann in diese journalistische Welt reingeschafft. Aber meine Güte, was musstest du da auch dich durchboxen und dann auch letztlich auch Glück haben, dass sich dann doch noch mal jemand gefunden hat, der dir überhaupt eine Chance gegeben hat?
Das stimmt schon, aber ich würde dir trotzdem insofern, ich widerspreche dir selten, das weißt du, aber ich würde dir insofern widersprechen, dass aus deiner Sicht, Max, mit deinem analytischen Geist und dass du das Spiel an sich betrachtest und für dich kein Unterschied ist, ob es ein Männer- oder ein Frauenspiel ist, geht es aber dennoch für ganz, ganz viele Menschen, wenn wir über dieses Ökosystem Fußball sprechen, geht es auch um Kontextualisierung. Da geht es auch um Narrative, da geht es um Persönlichkeiten, da geht es um Geschichten, dass du die Spieler kennst. Und das alles fehlt im Fußball der Frauen. Und ich glaube, du brauchst diese Leuchtturmprojekte, wie eine Europameisterschaft, wie eine Weltmeisterschaft, dass du zumindest auf so einer ganz, ganz rudimentären Ebene Menschen wie diesen Kollegen, den du gerade angesprochen hast, ein bisschen in Kontakt bringst mit dem Fußball der Frauen, dass du ihn zumindest dazu bringst, mal die Nationalmannschaft zu sehen, indem du Kontexte schaffst, dass der eventuell Lena Oberdorf kennt, dass der eventuell Laura Freigang kennt, weil die ist ja so kultig und cool. Also du brauchst Kontext, um die Menschen, glaube ich, schon für den Fußball der Frauen zu öffnen. Und das schaffst du, glaube ich, nicht nur über das reine Spiel, das schaffst du über Persönlichkeiten, die du in den Medien besprichst, die du zeigst, die du mal in Podcasts einlädst. Das gehört auch alles zum Spiel mit dazu. Es ist nicht nur das reine Spiel. Und ich glaube, um die Menschen zum Fußball der Frauen zu bringen, brauchst du eben Geschichten, brauchst du Narrative, brauchst du Gesichter, brauchst du Side-Stories. Und das funktioniert oftmals auch über so eine etwas größere Berichterstattung. Ein Vorbericht, ein Vorbericht vor einem Spiel, wo du mal ein Interview hörst, wo du mal die Frau sprechen hörst. Auch das gehört zu einem Spiel mit dazu, warum du dich für ein Fußballspiel interessierst. Das glaube ich schon, nicht nur. Aber ich glaube, für die breite Masse, die vielleicht nicht nur einen analytischen Fußballblick auf dem Spiel hat, sondern auch gerne enttänt werden möchte, die braucht noch die Geschichte 3 und 4 dazu. Und ich glaube, das dürfen wir nicht ganz vergessen. Und dafür brauchst du diese Leuchtturmprojekte, diese Quotenerfolge, wo dann eventuell auch der Otto Normalverbraucher mal dieses Spiel schaut und mal einen Vorbericht mit Laura Freigang und Lena Oberdorf sieht und dann denkt, ach, die finde ich aber eigentlich ganz witzig. Also die ist ja witzig. Und dann erkennt er die das nächste Mal, ja? Oder folgt auf Instagram und kriegt dann mit, ah, Eintracht Frankfurt spielt jetzt im DFB-Pokal gegen den FC Bayern. Und krass, die sind ja sogar dritter in der Liga. Wahnsinn. Cool. So, also ich glaube, so kannst du schon Interesse pflanzen mit Kontext und Narrativen und Geschichten. Das, glaube ich, ist schon wichtig. Und ich glaube, ein anderes Thema ist das, was du jetzt aufgemacht hast, was meinen persönlichen Weg angeht, weil ich habe ja schon relativ schnell mich ja auch ausgiebig mit dem Fußball der Männer beschäftigen müssen, weil halt, als ich damals bei der Sportschau angefangen habe, das nun mal ja auch das omnipräsente Thema war. Also ich kam jetzt nicht als die Frau, die irgendwie den Frauenfußball bespricht, sondern ich kam als die Frau, die Fußball spielt, was mir eine gewisse Form der Kredibilität gegeben hat. Ah ja, die scheint sich ja wirklich auszukennen, weil die spielt ja selber. Also als Frau in diesem Medienbereich, Kathrin, das wirst du eventuell auch kennen, brauchst du eine Kredibilität, also du brauchst einen doppelten Boden, der dir Glaubwürdigkeit verleiht. Und der dir suggeriert, ah die möchte nicht nur berühmt werden, weil das wird ja Frauen dann immer unterstellt, sondern die interessiert sich wirklich für Fußball, weil die hat ja sogar gespielt. Und die hat ja dann offensichtlich schon auch Ahnung, weil die hat ja selber gespielt. Also du brauchst als Frau in diesem Medienbereich einen doppelten Boden und der ist oftmals gegeben, wenn du selber gespielt hast. So habe ich das wahrgenommen, dass mir das immer eine wahnsinnige Glaubwürdigkeit verliehen hat, dass ich selber ganz gut kicken konnte. Und ich glaube, das haben viele andere Frauen, die in diesem Bereich arbeiten, eventuell nicht, die sich vielleicht einfach für den Sport interessieren oder die einfach Lust auf Sportjournalismus haben. Ich glaube, die haben wirklich noch mit viel mehr Gegenwind zu rechnen, als ich es hatte. Und ich hatte schon Gegenwind. Und ich will mir gar nicht ausmalen, wie es für Frauen ist, die vielleicht nicht gespielt haben. Also da, glaube ich, haben sie noch ein viel, viel größeres Problem und eine größere Hürde und viel mehr Türen, die verschlossen sind.
Ja, das ist halt spannend, was du sagst, weil du bist natürlich dann auch immer die Frau. Also man ist ja nie nur seine eigene Person auch in dem Kontext, sondern man steht immer repräsentativ für alle Frauen. Das heißt, wenn du einen Versprecher hast, wenn du was Dummes sagst, dann haben Frauen keine Ahnung von Fußball. Nicht Lena Cassel hat in dem Moment keine Ahnung. Frauen haben keine Ahnung von Fußball. Und mir ging es ganz oft bei den Trainerlehrgängen so, dass ich diesen erhöhten Standard gespürt habe, dass ich genau zum einen mehr Glaubwürdigkeit oder sofort Respekt bekomme, weil ich habe ja bei Bayern München gespielt, aber auch nur, weil das halt ein erfolgreicher Verein der Männer ist. Ich habe auch beim FCR Duisburg gespielt, die waren damals genauso, die waren erfolgreicher als Bayern. Ich habe mehr Titel mit dem FCR gewonnen, aber wenn ich sage, ich habe beim FCR Duisburg gespielt, interessiert es keinen. Das gibt mir gar keine Glaubwürdigkeit, weil den Verein kennt im Männerbereich niemand. Und ich habe immer so dieses Gefühl gehabt, ich bin nicht nur Kathrin Längert, eine Frau, die Trainerin werden möchte, sondern ich bin die Frau im Lehrgang. Das heißt, ich stehe repräsentativ für alle und ich muss liefern. Wenn ich einen Fehlpass spiele in der Praxiseinheit, dann können Frauen keinen Fußball spielen. Wenn ich die falsche Antwort gebe im Seminar, dann weil Frauen keine Ahnung von Fußball haben. Ich nehme es zumindest bei den Kolleginnen im Journalismus ähnlich wahr, dass sie auch immer die Frau sind. Die eine Frau in der Redaktion soll ja auch immer über die Frauen berichten. Also könntet ihr euch nicht auch für die Männer interessieren. Ihr interessiert euch automatisch für Frauen, weil ihr Frauen seid. Und genau wie du sagst, dass man immer diesen erhöhten Standard hat, aber was weiß sie denn schon? Hat sie gespielt? War sie erfolgreich? Was hat sie überhaupt Ahnung? Das wird bei Männern einfach nicht so schnell in Frage gestellt. Und was ich zu deinem Vorherigen noch sagen wollte, dass wir auf jeden Fall diese Leuchttürme brauchen, um das Spotlight auf die Sportart zu kriegen oder auf den Sport. Aber dass ich finde, dazwischen sind die Lücken dann halt einfach zu groß. Also mir fehlt dann einfach genau in der wöchentlichen Berichterstattung Bundesliga-DFB-Pokal, da fehlen mir genau diese Fenster mit Vorberichterstattung, mit vernünftiger Halbzeit-Analyse, mit Nachberichten, mit einer vernünftigen Anstoßzeit, wo wirklich Leute einschalten können. Die Bundesliga ist immer noch versteckt bei Magenta TV, ja, bei The Zone. Du brauchst also diese wahnsinnig hohe Hürde, die Highlights der Spiele zu sehen. Da gibt es keine Sportschau für, da gibt es keine aktuelle Sportstudie, wo jede Woche eine Persönlichkeit eingeladen wird, die die Leute auch kennenlernen können. Diese ganzen Geschichten, von denen du berichtest, die die Emotionen herstellen, die die Verbindung herstellen, die liegen bei uns auf der Straße. Die sammeln nur keine ein, weil niemand mit Marina Hegering gesprochen hat, die sechs Jahre kein Fußball spielen konnte und dann wieder zur Nationalspielerin geworden ist. Oder mit Turit Knark, die eine Doktorarbeit parallel geschrieben hat. Oder jetzt eben meinetwegen mit Tabea Sellner, wo mich interessieren würde, warum musst du mit 28 aufhören? Du bist Mutter geworden, ist die Vereinbarkeit vielleicht doch noch nicht so weit. Wir haben so viel zu sagen, aber uns fragt niemand und die Sendezeit ist nicht da. Ich meine, selbst bei der Nations League wurde die Nachberichterstattung wieder in den Stream geschickt. Es ist immer noch so selbstverständlich, dass für die Frauen irgendwo ein Livestream angeworfen wird, zu dem ganz viele Leute allein technisch vielleicht gar nicht den Zugang haben. Und wir müssten diese Sichtbarkeit einfach durchgehend haben. Es müsste so selbstverständlich sein, dass man die Frauen gucken kann oder die Männer. Und nicht die Männer gibt es immer und überall. Und die Frauen vielleicht, wenn es irgendwo noch ein Platz frei ist zwischen rote Rosen und irgendwie ein Hafenkante.
Nach dem Biathlon um 16.55 Uhr.
Ja, Topspiel 16.55 Uhr.
Ja, und es ist so Quatsch, weil das Narrativ natürlich auch schon immer so gesetzt wird. Es interessiert sich ja keiner dafür. Deshalb können wir es nicht zeigen. Und das ist einfach eine Lüge. Also wir berichten bei MML Daily, dem täglichen Fußballpodcast, den ich ja noch mache, egal ob Männer- oder Frauenturnier, immer durch. Und während alle anderen Fußballpodcasts, außer der Rasenfunk, Pause machen, machen wir weiter. Und unsere Zuhörer in Zahlen brechen überhaupt nicht ein. Die Leute hören uns einfach weiter. Und von daher diese Erzählung, die die ganze Zeit von den Medienverantwortlichen dann nach außen propagiert wird. Es interessiert sich ja keiner dafür. Deshalb müssen wir irgendwie um 16.55 Uhr das Topspiel zeigen, weil sonst haben wir ja keinen Platz. Weil der prominenteste Sendeplatz ist dann halt für keine Ahnung, was du vorher gesehen hast, weil da mehr Leute einschalten. Das ist Quatsch. Und wenn du da halt wirklich auch so ein bisschen das Spotlight von den Männern, also an der richtigen Stelle Synergien schaffen und an der falschen, bitte nicht, aber an der richtigen Stelle Synergien schaffen, ich kann mich daran erinnern, dass The Zone einmal bei einer Champions League Konferenz auch ein Spiel der Champions League der Frauen einfach mit untergebracht hat. Also es war die Männerkonferenz und sie haben einfach auch noch das Frauenspiel mitgezeigt in der Konferenz, weil das auch parallel stattfand. Es hat sich niemand darüber beschwert. Also man hat dann so ein bisschen mitbekommen, was noch bei den Frauen passiert und ich glaube, natürlich würde ich es mir anders wünschen. Natürlich würde ich mir erst mal wünschen, dass es eine Champions League Frauenfußballkonferenz bei The Zone eigenständig gibt, aber ich glaube, soweit sind wir noch nicht. Und da müssen wir dann an der richtigen Stelle die Synergien schaffen, dass wir den Fußball der Frauen so prominent platzieren, dass auch Leute davon mitbekommen, die sich nicht eigenständig dafür interessieren würden. Und deshalb würde ich auch es strittig sehen, diese Montagsspiele jetzt der Frauen, ich glaube, das hat nicht funktioniert. Ich glaube, das hat nicht funktioniert, das Frauenfußballspiel auf einen Montag zu legen, wo die Männer ja schon gesagt haben beim Männerfußball, wir boykottieren das, wir wollen keine Montagsspiele, wir können das nicht konsumieren, weil wir da arbeiten, weil das nicht passt, wir können nicht auswärtsreisen usw. usf. Und ich glaube nicht, dass das sinnvoll war, dann den Frauen diesen Platz zu geben, weil er einfach nicht prominent ist, weil er nicht beliebt ist und dann hat man sich aber argumentativ damit rüsten können, naja, wir geben den Frauen ja ihren eigenen Platz.
Am Rand, wo niemand hin wollte.
Weil es am Rand ist, weil es nicht so funktioniert. Warum zeigen wir denn nicht in der Bundesliga-Konferenz der Männer am Samstag um 15.30 Uhr auch Spiele der Frauen, die zeitgleich stattfinden? Und ich weiß, dass es dann schwierig ist, dass man dann noch mehr Fans in die Stadien kriegt. Ja, aber ich weiß gar nicht, ob sich das so morfen würde. Ich glaube, die Zielgruppe der Menschen, die ein Frauenfußballspiel besuchen, was viele Familien zum Beispiel sind, weil die Tickets noch erschwinglich sind, weil du dich da hinstellen kannst, ohne bepöbelt zu werden, weil irgendwie das Environment noch ein bisschen was anderes ist, vielleicht mehr durchlässig ist auch, ist vielleicht eine ganz andere Zielgruppe als die Stadiongänger bei den Männerfußballspielen. Also warum öffnen wir uns da nicht mal und probieren es mal aus? Also dass es da eine Mix-Konferenz gibt, nur mal als Start, nur mal um Geschichten auch prominenter zu platzieren bei den Frauen, die durchaus da sind. Also ich würde es gerne mal ausprobieren.
Ja, ich glaube, wir haben ja auch inzwischen genug Expertinnen dabei bei den Konferenzen, die auch sofort ohne Probleme die Frauenberichterstattung super integrieren könnten. Ich finde auch, das Montagsspiel war also nicht mal ein gutes Angebot. Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass jemand wirklich auch gedacht hat, es ist eine gute Idee. Es waren mehr als fauler Kompromiss, um eine Diskussion erst einmal zum Erliegen zu bringen. Weil was wir nicht vergessen dürfen, ist nicht nur, dass die Spiele für Fans schwierig zu erreichen sind, die jetzt ins Stadion gehen wollen, sondern dass wir auch immer noch Spielerinnen haben, die arbeiten müssen, die in die Schule gehen, die studieren, auch in der ersten Bundesliga. Die müssen sich Urlaub nehmen, um zum Spiel zu fahren oder die arbeiten morgens noch vier Stunden und gehen dann zum Heimspiel. Das hat ja nichts mit fairen Leistungsgedanken zu tun, denen noch eine Barriere mehr hinzulegen. Ich bin auch dafür, dass die Frauen eine feste Anschlusszeit bekommen. Ich finde, bei den Männern ist die Kritik total berechtigt, dass die Spieltage so zerfranst wurden. Ich finde z.B., dass die Männer sonntags definitiv eine Anschlusszeit abgeben könnten. Kann 15.30 Uhr sein, kann 17.30 Uhr sein. Das ist dann die Frauenspielzeit. Da konkurriert man dann bestenfalls auch nicht mit Liga 2. Und da wissen alle, die sich dafür interessieren, ganz klar, jetzt kann ich die Frauen sehen oder eben ich kann auch ins Stadion gehen. Der Sonntag ist eh traditionell auch so der Spieltag der Frauen immer gewesen. Genau wie Lena sagt, da kommen viele mit Familien raus. Und ich finde einfach, das muss genauso selbstverständlich sein, dass es da eine feste Anschlusszeit gibt, wie es dem Männerfußball guttun würde, sich da wieder ein Stück zurückzunehmen. Weil das ist die Bedingung. Der Männerfußball wird auch an der einen oder anderen Stelle ein bisschen gesund schrumpfen müssen, um Platz zu machen. Nicht nur für die Frauen im Fußball, sondern für alle anderen Sportarten. Und ich finde, die Fans, die Ultras da haben ja auch einen Punkt mit dieser Zerfransung der Spieltage. Und ich glaube, dass das auch eine gute Lösung sein könnte, um die Frauen selbstverständlicher und prominenter in diesen ganzen Fußballzirkus zu integrieren.
Und die Geschichten, die kann man im Frauenfußball viel besser noch erzählen als im Männerfußball. Also ich meinte das vorhin gar nicht so analytisch, Lena, ich glaube jemand, der Journalist ist, der gerne Geschichten erzählen will über diese Unterhaltungsindustrie, da ist es halt ein bisschen peinlich zu sagen, für die Frauen interessiere ich mich nicht, weil die Geschichten sind da geiler, sei mal ganz ehrlich. Also das ist durch viele Dinge, die ihr jetzt schon angesprochen habt, ist das ja auch glaube ich schon klar geworden. Gleichzeitig haben wir dann aber natürlich ganz häufig das Argument, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gerade gar nicht mehr, in welchen der beiden Bücher ich das gelesen habe, die Studie, die herausgefunden hat, dass wenn man den Fußball der Frauen statistisch misst, dass der sich im Grunde fast gar nicht bei Kathrin war. Danke, es tut mir leid. Das ist der Nachteil, wenn man parallel in sehr kurzer Zeit zwei Bücher liest. Dass der sich statistisch gar nicht so sehr unterscheidet. Es gibt leichte Unterschiede in der Geschwindigkeit, aber das sind ja auch immer so Defensiv-Argumente, damit man sich mit etwas nicht auseinandersetzen muss. Dass man einfach pauschal das Urteil fällt, das ist einfach schlechter und deswegen wollen wir es nicht sehen. Und dass das totaler Quatsch ist, darüber muss dann gar nicht mehr diskutiert werden, weil die Diskussion ist ja dann scheinbar an diesem Punkt schon beendet. Was aber ja definitiv der Fall ist, ist, dass es eine schlechter Behandlung von Frauen gibt, die dann eben versuchen, aus dem Mädchenfußball in den Frauenfußball zu kommen und ja auch irgendwie anklopfen an Regionalliga, Zweiterliga oder es vielleicht sogar in die erste Bundesliga schaffen. Und diese Ungleichbehandlung erklärt ja auch ganz, ganz viel, was man dann oben in der Spitze vielleicht dann auch manchmal im Bundesliga-Übertragung sehen kann an eben dem Drum herum, dass es da so gibt. Deswegen würde ich da gerne mit euch beiden nochmal drüber sprechen. Kathrin, was du es ja in den Profifußball richtig reingeschafft hast, was waren denn für dich eigentlich dann so die, wenn du im Nachhinein nochmal drüber nachdenkst, die wichtigsten Faktoren, die auf der einen Seite dir zwar diesen Weg ermöglicht haben, aber die es dir auch immer wieder so viel schwerer gemacht haben als den vielen, vielen Jungs, die eben irgendwann in einem NSZ landen und die auch einen schwierigen Weg haben. Ich will das nicht kleinreden, aber denen dann doch so viel abgenommen wird, worüber sie vielleicht gar nicht nachdenken.
Ja, vielleicht zu deinem Einstieg nochmal, was mir eben ganz wichtig war im Buch, ist, dass es ja keine klassische Biografie geworden ist, sondern dass ich quasi dachte, ich habe ja während meines Masterstudiums auch an der Uni gearbeitet, also nach meinem Karriereende in der Forschung gearbeitet und dachte mir, ich sammel jetzt einfach alle Daten. Ich sammle einfach alle Argumente, die ich finden kann, alles, was sich statistisch belegen lässt, damit wir immer aus diesen gefühlten Wahrheiten rauskommen, dass der Fußball qualitativ schlechter ist, dass das keiner sehen will. Diese ganzen Totschlagargumente, die sich tatsächlich eben in der Realität so nicht beweisen lassen, weil ich einfach vermeiden wollte, dass irgendjemand, irgendein Leser, eine Leserin sagen kann, ja, das war ihre Erfahrung. Die hat halt Pech gehabt. Die hatte halt da und da einen schlechten Trainer oder der Verein hat es nicht gut gemacht, sondern wenn du was Strukturelles beweisen willst, dann musst du ja auch zeigen, dass es eigentlich überall so ist, über einen ganz langen Zeitraum und überregional. Und wofür ich eben verschiedene Studien gefunden habe, ist eben, dass wenn du Frauenspiele anonymisierst, also die Spieler unkenntlich machst oder sogar digital veränderst, da gab es ja vor der WM dieses berühmte Video der französischen Telekommunikationsgesellschaft Orange, dass man dann keinen Unterschied mehr bemerkt, dass quasi Männer denen das gezeigt wird, auch Frauen denen das gezeigt wird, nicht mehr sagen können, ist das Männer- oder Frauenfußball, und dass sie, wenn es eben als Männerfußball digital verändert wird, das auch positiver bewerten, automatisch, einfach nur, weil es Männer sind, die sie spielen sehen. Das heißt, da sehen wir ja, dass es eben einfach mit Sehgewohnheit zu tun hat und mit der kulturellen Praxis, dass Männerfußball angeblich besser sein soll als Frauenfußball, per se. Also das lässt sich einfach statistisch nicht halten und das habe ich da anhand verschiedener Beispiele nachgewiesen. Was ich zu meiner eigenen Fußballsozialisation sagen kann, ist, dass ich den Weg auf jeden Fall geschafft habe wegen Elternhaus. Das ist beim Frauenfußball ein ganz entscheidender Faktor. Du brauchst nämlich Eltern, die, wie gesagt, genug Zeit haben, dich zu unterstützen, weil du meistens zu einem guten Verein weiterfahren musst, weil auch zum Beispiel du zu Auswärtsspielen mit Eltern fahren musst. Das heißt, da müssen Menschen vorhanden sein, die Autos haben, die Zeit haben, die Geld für Sprit haben, weil all das war beim Verein nicht gegeben. Ich habe damals schon bei einem Bundesligisten beim FC Duisburg in der Jugend gespielt. In Essen war damals noch nicht mal Bundesliga-Fußball vorhanden. Deswegen musste ich überhaupt wechseln. Das heißt, es kommt ganz viel soziale Herkunft. Wie gut können die dich unterstützen? Wie gut können die dir Sportklamotten kaufen? Ich habe auch Schuhe und Handschuhe ganz lange selbst bezahlt. Man war immer froh, wenn man zur Jugendnationalmannschaft nominiert wurde, weil dann hat man einmal so eine große Adidas-Tasche bekommen mit Schuhen und Handschuhen. Da wusste man, okay, für diese Saison habe ich jetzt schon mal ausgesorgt. Das war mit der größten Anspornung, um nominiert zu werden. Also daran habe ich, glaube ich, schon einen Entscheidungsfaktor, warum man es dann weit schaffen kann oder nicht weit schaffen kann. Unabhängig davon natürlich, dass man hart arbeitet, viel trainiert, viele Entbehrungen hat. Der Unterschied zu den Jungs war mir gar nicht so klar, weil ich keine Jungs kannte, die im Leistungsfußball in dem Moment waren. Die NLZs kamen ja auch erst im neuen Jahrtausend. Denen stehe ich auch aus ganz anderen Gründen kritisch gegenüber, wo ich gemerkt habe, dass es schwerer für mich ist, weil ich eine Frau bin. Das ist natürlich, nachdem ich es einmal in die Bundesliga geschafft habe. Weil du einfach denkst, wenn du diesen Sprung schaffst und dich da etablierst, also nicht nur irgendwie mal spielst eine Saison oder so, sondern da wirklich Jahre bist, dass du dann zum Beispiel finanziell einfach komfortabel leben kannst. Das war jetzt bei mir nicht der Fall. In meiner ersten Saison als Nummer eins in Duisburg hatte ich ja noch den Jugendspielerinnenvertrag. Ich habe ja mit 17 für 250 Euro unterschrieben. Also ich habe in meiner ersten Saison habe ich mich wirklich angestrengt, dass wir gewinnen, weil ich die Punktprämie und die Auflaufprämie schon gebraucht habe für Miete und Auto und alles weitere. Also es war ökonomisch einfach super anstrengend, obwohl ich halt doppelt gearbeitet habe, weil ich bin zur Uni gegangen und ich habe Fußball gespielt auf allerhöchstem Niveau. Wir haben fast jeden Tag trainiert. Wir waren die Wochenenden auf Auswärtsspielen. Und wenn du dann halt die Champions League gewinnst, so wie wir 2009, die ist ja damals noch UEFA Women's Cup, und hast da irgendwie so eine dreistellige Siegprämie hinterher, also ich kann mich nicht mal mehr erinnern. Keine von uns kann sich erinnern. Ich habe so viele gefragt, wisst ihr noch, wie viel Geld wir bekommen? Also das war nicht viel. Also da hast du ja nicht ausgesorgt. Der Erfolg bringt dir nichts. Die Wertschätzung fehlt, weil Geld ist auch Anerkennung. Und dieses Märchen von Leistung muss sich lohnen. Und wenn du nur hart genug arbeitest und so, dann kommt irgendwie der Ruhm. Und dann kommt das Geld. Dafür habe ich nicht gespielt. Das ist es nicht. Aber du möchtest natürlich irgendwann mal was dafür in den Händen halten, dass du all diese Entbehrungen auf dich genommen hast und dass dein Körper so viel geschafft hat und dass du so viel geleistet hast. Und das kam bei den Frauen einfach viel zu wenig oder gar nicht.
Betrifft natürlich auch noch ganz viele andere Sportarten. Also ich sehe schon die Kommentare vor mir, die darauf hinweisen, in anderen Sportarten ist es noch viel schlimmer. Das stimmt, aber wir reden jetzt eben gerade über die eine Sportart, die sich in Deutschland aus ganz vielen Gründen durchgesetzt hat und in der irre viel Geld unterwegs ist. Deswegen hat es dann halt dann doch nochmal, glaube ich, eine andere Bedeutung, wenn wir jetzt über Fußball sprechen und nicht über Handball, Eishockey, Basketball, Volleyball und so weiter.
Ja, das ist auch so ein bisschen Whataboutism. Also ich bin total solidarisch mit allen meinen Kollegen in den anderen Sportarten. Ich habe ja auch viele von denen kennengelernt im Olympiastützpunkt in München. Wir haben uns ja da eine Physiotherapie geteilt und die Krafträume und so. Ganz tolle Athletinnen. Ich habe mich auch immer mega geschämt, wenn ihr alle erzählt haben, wie viel die trainieren, weil niemand so wenig trainiert, glaube ich, wie Fußballerinnen. Ja, wirklich. Also ganz krass, was die da für 400 Euro Sporthilfe und irgendwie eine Stelle beim Zoll leisten. Aber genau wie du sagst, wir können halt immer nur ein Thema nach dem anderen behandeln. Und dafür bin ich halt nicht Expertin, aber dass generell der Sport in Deutschland unterfinanziert ist, ist auch ein offenes Geheimnis. Und dass du für eine Goldmedaille 20.000 Euro vor Steuern kriegst, ist genauso eine Frechheit.
Lena, wie war denn da dein Weg? Also ich meine, man kann es ja sehr schön bei dir nachlesen. Da hat auch ein Zugausfall eine wichtige Rolle gespielt, muss man sagen. Und du hast dann irgendwann auch eine andere Entscheidung getroffen. Aber was würdest du sagen, war im Nachhinein das größte strukturelle Hindernis, über das du springen musstest?
Ich glaube, das, was Kathrin Schuh gesagt hat, wichtiger Aspekt, die soziale Herkunft, das Elternhaus, was sich natürlich dann schon auch unterstützt, was sich finanziell auch auffangen kann, das war bei mir nicht gegeben. Primär war bei mir relativ schnell klar, mit 17, als ich ausgezogen bin, ich muss Geld verdienen und ich muss arbeiten und ich muss mich irgendwie selber finanzieren, weil ich kein soziales Netz hatte, was mich in der Form dann auffangen kann, um meinen Traum zu verwirklichen. Also klar, vielleicht hätte es jetzt auch vom Talent her nicht ganz für die Bundesliga gereicht.
Du hast aus 200 Metern ein Wolle-Tor geschossen, habe ich gelesen.
Danke, dass du das erwähnst, Max. Danke, dass du das noch mal erwähnst. Aber die 2. Bundesliga war durchaus zeitweise ein Thema. Du hast den Edvigenwechsel zum 1. FC Köln ja schon angesprochen, wo ich leider nie ankam beim Probetraining, weil die Deutsche Bahn nicht weiterfuhr. Ich saß in einem schneebedeckten Zug fest und habe das Probetraining verpasst. Ich bin ja wahnsinnig abergläubisch und habe dann es so für mich verargumentiert. Vermutlich hatte ich aber auch nur einfach Schiss. Habe gesagt, es soll nicht sein. Ich werde nicht zum ersten FC Köln-Probetraining gehen. Ich werde kein neues Verein bahnen. Und irgendwann kam dann aber der SV Fortuna Köln um die Ecke und wollte mich sozusagen haben. Ich habe ja damals noch in der Verbandsliga gespielt. Bei einem Dorfverein namens SV Elner Bödingen. Ich habe da sechs Jahre lang gespielt. Und der SV Fortuna Köln wollte mich also haben. Und der SV Elner Bödingen hat gesagt, naja, ihr könnt Lena haben, aber wir wollen eine Ausbildungsentschädigung dafür haben. Denn die Spielerin, die Lena jetzt ist, haben wir ausgebildet. Das bedeutete, der SV Elner Bödingen wollte eine Ablöse von mir haben. Also für mich haben es 500 Euro. 500 Euro, die ich dem SV Fortuna Köln allerdings nicht wert war, weil sie keine Ablöse für Spielerinnen bezahlen. Die Betonung liegt da auf Innen, weil für Männer bezahlen sie den natürlich, aber halt nicht für Frauen, weil kein Budget-Top dafür da sei. Long story short, ich musste also meine Ablöse, wenn ich zum SV Fortuna Köln hätte wechseln wollen, selber aufbringen. Also ich musste mich also selber kaufen. Findet mal 500 Euro als Anfang 20-Jährige, als Studentin, die wirklich jeden Cent umdrehen musste, war schwierig. Ein Finanzier tauchte dann dennoch auf. Es war mein Opa Herbert, der die 500 Euro Ablöse für mich bezahlte und somit konnte ich zum SV Fortuna Köln wechseln, allerdings auch ohne Vertrag. Also ich habe keinen Amateurvertrag bekommen, obwohl wir in der dritten Liga gespielt haben, in der Regionalliga. Ich habe kein Geld bekommen, ich hatte keine Versicherung, ich hatte gar nichts. Ich habe aber dennoch vier bis fünf Mal die Woche dort auf dem Trainingsplatz gestanden, Auswärtsfahrten organisiert am Sonntag, der ganze Tag war weg. Und irgendwann habe ich aber dann angefangen, bei der Sportschau zu arbeiten und habe auch vorher nebenbei immer gearbeitet. Und die Sportschau-Zeiten, die kollidierten aber eben mit diesem Sonntag 15 Uhr, wo eben der Frauenfußball gespielt hat, mit den Zeiten der Männer Bundesliga, wo ich dann für die Sportschau im Einsatz war. Das bedeutet also, ich musste teilweise nach der ersten Halbzeit gehen, weil ich arbeiten musste bei der Sportschau. Und mein Trainer sagte dann irgendwann zu mir, Lena, ich kann dich eigentlich auch nicht mehr aufstellen, weil mit dir habe ich direkt einen Wechsel verloren, weil du in der Halbzeit immer weggehen musst zum Arbeiten. Das wird ein Problem werden. Also musste ich mich irgendwann entscheiden. Ich musste mich entscheiden zwischen meiner semiprofessionellen Fußballkarriere und meiner Karriere oder dem Geldverdienen bei der Sportschau. Und dann habe ich mich für die Sportschau entschieden und gegen meine semiprofessionelle Fußballkarriere, weil ich auf der einen Seite Geld verdienen musste und auf der anderen Seite eben kein Geld verdient habe mit dem Fußballspielen, sondern eben nur mit dem bei der Sportschau arbeiten. Und das waren die Hürden, mit denen ich zu kämpfen hatte, warum ich dann eventuell nicht den Sprung in die zweite Bundesliga geschafft habe, weil es nicht anders möglich war. Und das sind dann, glaube ich, die Geschichten, die du nur im Fußball der Frauen findest und nicht im Fußball der Männer findest, weil du da in der dritten Liga schon einen vierstelligen Betrag mindestens verdienst, der dir zumindest die Miete und eventuell auch das Auto bezahlen kann. Und das ist im Fußball der Frauen eben ganz, ganz anders. Also ich habe in der Regionalliga West gespielt und ich habe keinen einzigen Cent verdient.
Ja und ich finde, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, den du da nennst, weil wir haben darüber gesprochen, dass wir ganz viele Mädchen nicht erreichen, weil die gar nicht mit Fußball anfangen können. Aber ich glaube, wir haben vergessen zu erwähnen, wie viele wir zwischendurch verlieren. Weil sie im Fußball nicht bleiben können. Weil sich eben, weil sich für Frauen viel zu oft Scheidewege auf tun, wo du dich entscheiden musst. Gehe ich jetzt studieren oder spiele ich Fußball? Für mich war es zum Beispiel auch, als das Angebot kam, als ich, ich glaube, als ich 14 war, als das Angebot aus Duisburg kam, ob ich halt für die in der Jugend spielen will. Ich habe halt vorher in Essen gespielt. Die haben einmal weniger die Woche trainiert. Die haben halt in der zweiten Liga gespielt. Duisburg hat erste Liga gespielt und dreimal die Woche dann trainiert. Und da war dann so das erste Mal schon, wo ich mich so entscheiden musste, möchte ich das jetzt hier leistungsmäßig weiterführen, möchte ich Richtung, also versuchen weit zu kommen, möchte ich versuchen, das zu schaffen. Und das ging eben nur, weil klar war, meine Eltern können mich dreimal die Woche fahren. Oder dann später auch. Mendy Islaka kommt ja zum Glück auch aus Essen, zum Beispiel. Dass klar war, es gibt mehr Mädchen aus Essen. Wir können, wir haben eine Fahrgemeinschaft, wir kommen dahin. Ja, und solche Wegmarker kommen halt immer wieder. Und noch in meiner aktiven Zeit, ich habe ja auch erst 2017 aufgehört, hattest du immer wieder Spielerinnen, vor allem in kleinen Vereinen, die mit Mitte 20 aufgehört haben, weil dann das Studium vorbei war, oder die in ihrer Firma inzwischen ganz gut etabliert waren nach der Ausbildung und für die klar war, die können jetzt da einfach auch deutlich mehr Geld verdienen. Ich muss das so sagen, ich habe ja auch studiert, wäre ich mit Mitte 20 ins Lehramt gegangen, ich hätte mehr Geld verdient als als Fußball-Nationalspielerin. Ich hätte einfach mehr Netto gehabt. Ich habe Geld verloren und auch Karrierechancen jetzt nach dem Fußball, weil man ja zehn Jahre später einsteigt als alle anderen. Ja, also ich habe wirtschaftlichen Schaden erlitten, weil ich eine Fußballkarriere bis zu Ende durchgespielt habe. Und es ist im Traineramt übrigens überhaupt nicht anders. Also wir kommen jetzt ja dann auch dahin, dass der DFB alles professionalisieren will und dann sagt, so ab jetzt sind alle TrainerInnen in Vollzeit. Da möchte ich gerne mal fragen, wie viel ist denn Vollzeit? Weil ich habe schon einen Job angeboten bekommen in der ersten Bundesliga. Ich sage jetzt nicht, bei welchem Club. Es war nicht Essen als Torwart-Trainerin für 1200 Netto. So und ich verdiene aber als Lehrerin deutlich, deutlich mehr. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, warum sollte ich mich dann entscheiden, Vollzeit als Torwart-Trainerin zu arbeiten, wenn ich in einem anderen Beruf meinen Lebensunterhalt besser leisten kann? Plus Vereinbarkeit Familie und Beruf. Ich bin jetzt ja auch noch Mutter geworden. Ich habe jetzt noch nicht die Regularien gefunden, die mir jetzt irgendwie absichern, wer eine Betreuungsperson bezahlt, wer das Familienzimmer bezahlt, wie ich mit einem Baby zu einem Auswärtsspiel reisen kann. Also diese ganzen Aspekte von Zugang, von Sichtbarkeit, von auch Absicherung. Lena hat ja zu Recht gesagt, sie hatte auch gar keine Versicherung. Ja, was passiert, wenn du dir da das Knie zerfetzt und danach musst du noch 40 Jahre als Physiotherapeutin arbeiten? Also es gibt so viele Unsicherheiten für uns, die immer wieder dafür sorgen, dass sich Frauen dagegen entscheiden müssen, weil es einfach keinen Sinn macht oder sie es einfach nicht mehr leisten können, weil die Belastung auch so unglaublich hoch ist, wenn du denn wirklich deine ganze Sportkarriere lang doppelt und dreifach arbeitest.
Und das ist eben auch wirklich kein zu unterschätzender Punkt, nicht nur eben wegen der Spielerinnenbiografien. Also das ist ja wirklich, das kannst du ja eigentlich auf einen Witz zusammenfassen. Bei den Männern, wenn du mit ihnen sprichst, warum bist denn du kein Profifußballer, dann war es immer die Knieverletzung. Natürlich der einzige Grund. Und bei Frauen ist es ja, ich musste halt irgendwann arbeiten oder Geld verdienen, weil es nicht mehr anders ging. Es war nicht mehr miteinander vereinbar. Aber es ist insofern auch ein wichtiger Punkt, weil wir hier ja auch durchaus uns in der rechtlichen Grauzone bewegen. Also die Spielerinnen-Verträge, die es dann gibt und nicht alle unterschreiben ja überhaupt welche und die Vereine wissen genau, warum nicht alle einen unterschreiben. Weil du kommst dann nämlich ganz schnell in die Mindestlohn-Debatte rein, wo du dann nämlich feststellen musst, bei dem Aufwand, den Spielerinnen betreiben, um ihrem Sport nachzugehen, landen die bei einem Mindestlohn. Da kannst du froh sein, wenn der bei 4 oder 5 Euro ist, aber nicht bei den 12 Euro irgendwas, die er sein sollte. Und das ist durchaus auch juristisch ein Thema. Ich habe mal einen O-Ton, den ich dann hier einspielen möchte. Das ist aus einem Sport-and-Side-Beitrag von Markus Barg. Das ist der Jurist Philipp S. Fischinger. Der hat da kurz auf die Frage geantwortet, wann müsste man denn eigentlich nach Mindestlohn bezahlt werden?
Es ist letztlich immer eine Frage des Einzelfalls. Man müsste sich alle Faktoren anschauen. Das muss man klar betonen. Allerdings, wer im Prinzip genötigt ist, regelmäßig zum Training zu kommen, dem vorgegeben wird, wann er trainiert, was er trainiert, wo er trainiert, ob er spielt, wie er spielt. Das spricht sehr viel für die Arbeitnehmer-Eigenschaft. Die Folge wäre dann, dass die Chancen für die Klage gut wären.
Jetzt möchte ich mal ganz kurz wissen, wer von denjenigen, der das gerade gehört hat, nicht gesagt hat, uns wurde gesagt, wo wir trainieren, wann wir trainieren, wie wir trainieren. Meine These dazu, das ist ein riesiges Thema, das sehr selten aufgebohrt wird. Und gleichzeitig ist das ja nur die eine Ebene. Wir haben die finanzielle Entschädigung, die braucht man und die ist auch richtig und die soll da sein. Und wenn es so wäre, dass man nach Leistung verdient, müssten eigentlich die Frauen, die nebenher noch eine Ausbildung, ein Studium, einen Beruf ausüben, mehr verdienen als die Männer, die in Anführungszeichen nur Leistungssportler sind. Aber das andere ist ja, und das hast du gerade angesprochen Kathrin, dass man ja auch, wenn man Leistungssport betreibt, dann ist das nicht so, wie wenn ich kicken gehe. Da tut mir danach ein bisschen, tut mir alles weh, weil ich bin nicht mehr durchtrainiert und so weiter und so fort. Aber man betreibt Raubbau am eigenen Körper. Und was du geschrieben hast in deinem Buch zu den medizinischen Angeboten, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man es Angebot nennen sollte, die du in deiner Profikarriere hast, das war eigentlich, finde ich, mit der Erschütterungste. Dabei wusste ich davon einiges ja schon. Du warst ja schon bei Mara im Podcast. Wir haben schon drüber gesprochen. Aber kannst du noch mal kurz für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, die das Buch noch nicht gelesen haben und es danach aber bitte noch tun, noch mal kurz zusammenfassen, was ist denn dir in deiner Karriere überhaupt passiert an gesundheitlichem Schaden, der dir vielleicht für immer in deinem Leben bleiben wird?
Ja, das ist wirklich eine ganz wichtige Debatte, die oft zu kurz kommt. Es wird immer so prominent dieses Equal Pay-Thema platziert. Und das hat auch eine Berechtigung, weil ich fordere im Buch ja unter anderem auch einen Mindestlohn und erkläre auch, warum es den geben muss. Aber die Spielerinnen weisen ja in Interviews auch oft auf dieses Equal-Play-Thema hin. Und mir war ganz wichtig, in dem Buch diese drei Hauptkapitel mal aufzumachen. Equal Pay, Equal Play und der DFB. Also was macht der Verband, der für unseren Spielbetrieb ja immer noch hauptverantwortlich ist? Weil das eben die Themen sind, die in den Medien manchmal vorkommen, aber wo irgendwie im direkten Gespräch, ich oft merke, die Leute haben gar nicht so richtig Ahnung, was dahinter steckt, was die jetzt genau meinen. Und das Medizinenthema ist ein Aspekt eben des Equal Plays, wo, glaube ich, die allgemeine Vorstellung ist, weil wir eben den Männerfußball so gut kennen und der so groß präsentiert ist, dass dann die Spieler nach dem Training sich auf die Massagebank legen und dann wird dann groß ausmassiert und nach dem Spiel geht es irgendwie in die Eistonne, ins Entmüdungsbecken. Und das sind alles Bedingungen, die wir einfach nicht hatten. Also wir hatten so, ich sage mal, die Standardfrage bei jedem Training war, ist heute ein Physio da? Damit geht es ja schon mal los. Ich meine, Lena wird es noch viel schlimmer erlebt haben in der Regionalliga. Aber selbst beim FC Bayern war es jetzt halt so, ist heute ein Physio da? Also es war nicht mal bei jedem Training medizinisches Personal vor Ort. Es gab dann vielleicht einen Medizinkoffer in der Kabine. Dann hat man sich halt selber getapet. Ich kann so gut tapen für jemanden, der gar keine medizinische Ausbildung hat. Ich kann alle. Ich kann Sprunggelenke. Ich kann Hände. Ich kann auch Kinesio-Tape. Muskulatur, kein Problem, Knie. Wir haben uns einfach gegenseitig getapet. Gut war immer, wenn eine eine Ausbildung zur Physiotherapeutin gemacht hat, dann hattest du schon mal eine mit Expertise. Aber die Arme war ja eigentlich da, um Fußball zu spielen, um ihren Job zu machen und wurde dann bei den Auswärtsspielen noch als Physiotherapeutin missbraucht. Die konnte sich gar nicht aufs Spiel konzentrieren. Die musste erst mal noch vier Leute vorversorgen, damit es halt losgehen kann. Was ich im Endeffekt auch sagen kann, glaube ich, ist, dass mich zumindest teilweise auch die medizinische Unterversorgung vielleicht ein paar Karrierejahre gekostet hat. Muss man einfach so sagen. Ich meine, da haben auch andere Faktoren reingespielt. Ich war immer brutal übergeizig. Ich habe mich mit Sicherheit auch nicht immer an die vorgegebenen Regenerationszeiten gehalten. Aber es gab auch viel Druck von außen, muss man auch sagen. Natürlich immer zu spielen, sich immer irgendwie auch krank noch auf den Platz zu stellen, mit einer Verletzung vielleicht eine Woche früher zu probieren, weil das Spiel ist wichtig und wir haben sonst keinen. Aber am Ende des Tages habe ich mit 30 aufgehört und ich hatte eine Hüftverletzung, Adduktorenverletzung am Ende. Ich weiß es bis heute nicht, weil es halt nicht richtig diagnostiziert wurde. Unser Physiotherapeut in Jena damals war glaube ich im ersten Lehrjahr. Wir hatten ganz oft auch Auszubildende als Physiotherapeutinnen, weil die halt einfach billiger waren. Die wurden doch genauso ausgebeutet. Da ist dann einer für 50 Euro dreimal die Woche gekommen und hat irgendwie 100 Kilometer Busfahrt am Wochenende mitgemacht, weil es für die halt ein großes Sprungbrett war. Erfahrung zu sammeln und irgendwie in der Sportphysiotherapie Karriere zu machen. Wir hatten auch super, super viele sehr gute Physiotherapeuten, aber die waren dann oft in externen Praxen angestellt. Da musstest du dir ein Rezept besorgen beim Mannschaftsarzt und bist dann zusätzlich zu deiner Belastung mit Arbeit, Schule oder Training halt dann noch privat hingefahren in deiner Freizeit und hast dich da behandeln lassen, hast dich da tapen lassen. Und ich hatte eben zum Schluss eine schwierige Hüftverletzung, eine Adduktorenverletzung. Ich konnte nicht mehr schießen, das ist jetzt als Fußballspielerin relativ schwierig, auch als Torhüterin und bin ein halbes Jahr ausgefallen. Ich weiß bis heute nicht warum quasi, ich hatte einfach jeden Tag Schmerzen, ich konnte nicht mal gehen und konnte das dann in einer langen Reha-Phase, in der Sommerpause noch mal halbwegs stabilisieren. Ich bin dann noch mal eingestiegen zur Saison 16, 17, am ersten Spiel darin Leverkusen gespielt. Ich habe sogar ein richtig gutes Spiel gemacht, ich war total erleichtert, weil es ja mein erstes Pflichtspiel dann auch für Jena war. Die hatten ja auch große Hoffnung, glaube ich, in mich gesetzt oder in meine Verpflichtung. Und irgendwann in der zweiten Halbzeit musste ich einen langen Ball, der hinter die Kette gespielt wurde, halt klären, habe den weggeschossen, habe die Stelle gemerkt und dann wusste ich halt, okay, das war's. Also ich wusste eigentlich am ersten Spieltag quasi schon, das ist meine letzte Saison, weil ich wusste, wenn das jetzt nicht weg ist, nach sechs Monaten Reha, ich habe alles probiert, ich war in externen Kliniken, ich war im Wasserbecken mit den Omas morgens um sieben, habe Aquagymnastik gemacht, ich wusste dann, dann wird es nie mehr ganz weggehen und ist es auch nicht. Also und das ist halt so was, wo ich sage, ich kann noch nicht mal bei der BG Ansprüche stellen, weil ich habe gar keine MRT Bilder.
Also bei der Berufsgenossenschaft.
Ja genau, sorry, wir haben ja über Versicherungsschutz auch gesprochen. Jetzt bin ich zwar Lehrkraft, also ich habe Glück, ich habe Deutsch und Englisch studiert, aber wenn ich jetzt Sportlehrerin wäre, ich habe Kolleginnen, die hatten drei Kreuzbandrisse, die haben dann bei der Verbeamtung schon mal die eine oder andere Extrauntersuchung und müssen auch da Angst haben, dass es halt Konsequenzen für ihre weitere Berufslaufbahn hat. Also diese medizinische Unterversorgung sorgt dafür, dass es für uns Frauen viel wahrscheinlicher ist, dass du irreparable Schäden mitnimmst in die Zeit nach deiner Karriere, die dich dann nicht nur gesundheitlich beeinträchtigen, sondern die dich auch eventuell in deinem weiteren Berufsweg hindern, weil nochmal, auch wenn du die Knöchel kaputt hast und hast dann Physiotherapeutin gelernt oder hast Friseurin gelernt und hast halt was, wo du stehen musst, das hat alles Auswirkungen und auch die 40 Jahre danach kompensiert dir ja keiner, weil du hast ja einfach finanziell nicht ausgesorgt. Du musst mit diesem Körper danach noch ganz regulär arbeiten, wie alle anderen deutschen ArbeitnehmerInnen auch und ja, das ist halt was, wo ich weiß, dass es deutlich besser geworden ist, müssen wir sagen. Viele Vereine haben da einen großen Schritt nach vorne gemacht, aber spätestens, wenn wir in Liga 2 gucken, weiß ich schon, da ist dann wieder, da ist dann wieder nada so und da wird dann wieder einfach Ibuprofen genommen vor dem Spiel, um zu gucken, ob es geht. Aber da fehlt einfach medizinische Infrastruktur, um diesen Frauen auch gerecht zu werden. Und da sind wir noch nicht dabei, dass Menstruation immer noch völlig unerforscht ist und unser Zyklus keine Rolle spielt bei der Trainingsplanung.
Und vor allen Dingen, wenn du über das Thema Equal Play sprichst und dass die Spielerinnen das fordern, so auf dieser ganz unterschwelligen Ebene, ist es dann zumindest abgesichert zu sein. Genau dann, wenn du dich verletzt, dass du einen Amateurvertrag hast und damit eben auch Anspruch auf eventuell eine verletzte Rente, so nennt man das, also wenn du später nämlich bleibende Schäden hast, dass du dann auch eine Entschädigung bekommst, weil du dich eben bei deiner Arbeit verletzt hast. Und wenn du keinen Vertrag hast, da geht es noch nicht mal darum, dass du da wirklich Unsummen an Geld verdienst, sondern es geht um schlicht und ergreifende Absicherung, weil das nun mal ein Kontaktsport ist, wo auch unter anderem Frauen, die auf schlechteren Plätzen spielen, wo die Menstruation nicht mit einberechnet worden ist, wo du gar nicht weißt, was dein Zyklus eventuell auch für eine Auswirkung auf eventuelle Verletzungsanfälligkeit hat. Es gibt ja mittlerweile auch eine Korrelation zwischen Kreuzbandrissen und dem Zyklus. Das ist alles nicht erforscht. Das heißt, Frauen brauchen eigentlich noch einen höheren Schutz als Männer in diesem Sport, weil sie eben natürlich unterversorgt sind, weil es eben nicht die Infrastruktur gibt. Das heißt, der Bedarf eines Vertrages ist noch viel größer als der bei den Männern. Darum ging es mir eben auch bei meiner Drittligatätigkeit da als Spielerin von Fortuna Köln, dass ich einfach mich einem Verletzungsrisiko ausgesetzt habe und ich einfach nicht abgesichert war. Das war auch ein Aspekt neben dem, dass ich halt Geld verdienen musste, dass ich einfach Sorge hatte, mich zu verletzen, dementsprechend auch nicht mehr arbeitsfähig gewesen wäre. Ich muss in meinem Job sehr viel reisen und ich auch keine Entschädigung bekommen hätte. Und wir hatten zahlreiche Polizistinnen bei uns in der Mannschaft. Wenn sie ein Kreuzbanddres haben, die waren nicht mehr einsatzfähig. Und da hat dann teilweise auch der Arbeitgeber gesagt, wir verbieten dir das Fußballspielen, weil du dich einem solchen Verletzungsrisiko aussetzt. Du bist nicht abgesichert. Das können wir so nicht mehr leisten. Das ist nicht mehr tragbar. Und das sind natürlich Themen, die gar nicht so in dieser Debatte besprochen werden, weil immer ja primär nur über dieses Equal Pay Thema gesprochen wird, was wieder nur von der Spitze gedacht ist. Aber wir müssen da viel rudimentärer drüber reden, was das im Day by Day bei allen Spielerinnen auf der nicht super professionellen Ebene, sondern auf der semi professionellen Ebene bedeutet. Und wenn du über physiotherapeutische Behandlung sprichst, das sah bei uns so aus, dass wir einen kleinen Medizinkoffer hatten und darin war ein nasser Schwamm und eine kleine Flasche mit Wasser. Das war physiotherapeutische Behandlung.
Ja, ich muss so lachen, weil ich war ja auch Trainerin in der Jugend und die SGS Jugend hat ja in der Bundesliga auch gespielt, höchste Jugendliga, U17 Bundesliga. Und wir hatten dann tatsächlich in einer Saison den Fall, dass die Physiotherapeutin mitten in der Saison gekündigt hat, nämlich genau weil die ihre Abschlussprüfung hatte für ihre Ausbildung. Die war auch eine Auszubildende. Und dann hatten wir einfach bei jedem Spiel diesen Koffer dabei, wo ein trockener Schwamm drin lag. Das war alles, weil wir waren halt nur drei Trainerinnen, keine von uns hatte Ahnung. Und wir haben einfach immer so wirklich wie ein Placebo, wo so pro forma diesen leeren Koffer dahingestellt. Aber wenn sich eine verletzte, hat es nicht mehr passiert, als dass die Co-Trainerin hingerannt ist, hat die so ein bisschen über den Kopf gestrichen und gesagt, ist okay, geht wieder oder soll man mal kurz rausgehen. So das war dann halt die medizinische Versorgung. Und es ist so wichtig, dass du auch nochmal gesagt hast, wie das alles miteinander verzahnt ist. Ich habe dann im Buch da auch verschiedene Beispiele zu aufgeführt, auch zu Trainingsbedingungen, weil genau weil wir schlechtere Plätze haben, ist das Verletzungsrisiko höher. Wenn du dich verletzt, dann springt aber ja zum Beispiel nach, ich weiß nicht, sechs Wochen oder so, kriegst du ja dann nur noch kranken Tage Geld. Dann hast du, weil du so wenig Geld kriegst, auf einmal noch viel, viel weniger Geld. Also es war wirklich existenziell manchmal, wenn du dann auf dieses kranken Tage Geld gekommen bist, hattest du so wenig Netto im Monat, dass es schon wieder schwierig wurde mit Miete und Auto und allem. Und dann geht man schon mal eine Woche früher wieder zurück ins Mannschaftstraining. Also man darf wirklich nicht vergessen, für wie viele es dann auch existenziell wird. Und wenn wir beim Thema Zyklus sind, es ist ja nicht nur dieses Nischenthema nicht erforscht, sondern in der gesamten Sportwissenschaft ist meines Wissens nach, sind die meisten Studien, die meisten Trainingsempfehlungen alles basiert auf dem männlichen Körper. Ich denke, ich frage mich manchmal auch, ob wir so viele Kreuzbandrisse bei den Frauen erleben, weil die ganze Sportwissenschaft, die ganzen Trainingsumfänge auf männliche Körper ausgelegt sind. Es hat sich, glaube ich, niemals ernsthaft jemand damit beschäftigt, wie sollte denn die Saisonvorbereitung für Frauen aussehen. Und zwar nicht nur fußballspezifisch, sondern eben auch im Athletiktraining, in der Sportmedizin, alles ist am männlichen Körper erforscht.
Auch die Ausstattung, Fußballschuhe, Sport-BHs. Wir haben ja auch eine ganz andere Physiognomie, dadurch, dass wir Brüste haben. Guess what? Das heißt, wir haben eine ganz andere körperliche Ausstattung. Also brauchen wir auch eine andere Ausstattung eventuell, die uns schützt vor Verletzungen. Das sind Themen, die einfach nicht besprochen werden.
Ich glaube, wir sind massiv übertrainiert und massiv unterversorgt. In der Breite und auch noch in vielen Teilen der Spitze. Und da besteht so eine große Datenlücke, dass ich anstelle des DFB auch da als Erstes in Forschung investieren würde, weil wenn mir bei jedem Turnier vier Topspielerinnen mit Verletzungen fehlen, dann und auch natürlich die Vereine, auch in FC Bayern, auch in VfL Wolfsburg. Da wäre ich ja froh, wenn mir zum Saisonfinale die besten Frauen auch zur Verfügung stehen. Das wäre mir wirklich wert, dass sich in dem Bereich was tut, weil ich glaube, wir wissen gar nicht, unter welchen Bedingungen der weibliche Körper die besten Leistungen bringen kann, weil sich dann noch nie jemand ernsthaft mit beschäftigt hat.
Und interessanterweise landet man immer beim DFB. Der DFB würde jetzt dann sagen, ja, es ist Aufgabe der Vereine, die unterstützen wir dabei und so weiter und so fort. Und letztlich ist aber immer die Frage, von welcher Seite des Spektrums möchte man ein Problem angehen? Vorhin haben wir schon gesagt, es wäre viel wichtiger in die Basis zu investieren als eben in den Spitzensport. Und jetzt sind wir ja aber in einem Bereich, wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, vielleicht ist es hier jetzt dann umgedreht, dass man über Erkenntnisse, die man im absoluten Top-Segment erreicht, durch eine bessere Versorgung, durch eine bessere Studienlage, dann Erkenntnisse gewinnt, die man dann auch runterbringen kann, bis aufs Abateur-Level über die Liegen hinweg, über zum Beispiel auch Trainingsmaterialien. Das beschreibst du ja auch sehr schön in deinem Buch, Kathrin, dass ja Frauen gar nicht vorkommen in den Lizenzen vom DFB, wo ich vorher nicht drüber nachgedacht habe. Klar, ich bin ja ein Typ, wir denken oft über solche Dinge nicht nach. Aber das ist ja völlig absurd. Also das ist ja an Absurdität nicht zu überbieten, dass Frauen nicht mal, also auf keiner Folie, du hast es in einem Beispiel genannt, 168 Seiten Material. Keine einzige Frau ist überhaupt nur abgebildet. Aber das wäre jetzt dann meine Frage an dich, Kathrin. Wäre das dann vielleicht der Punkt, wo man sagen wirst, okay, hier setzen wir jetzt dann oben an und fangen im Leistungssport an, machen da die Studien, verbessern dort die Bedingungen und dann kann das vielleicht sich nach unten durchsetzen?
Absolut, weil da sind die Ressourcen vorhanden, da sind die Spielerinnen vorhanden, da ist die Zeit vorhanden. Da würde ich sagen, muss die Forschung quasi in der Spitze anfangen. Das müssen ja nicht nur Top-Vereine der ersten Bundesliga sein. Ich denke auch ganz oft zum Beispiel an Jugend-Nationalmannschaften, weil der DFB Ressourcen hat, weil eben, wie gesagt, ich davon überzeugt bin, dass viele Universitäten gerne mit dem DFB kooperieren würden, um sowas zu erforschen, weil wir ja eben auch die Erkenntnisse gerade im Jugendbereich brauchen, wo die körperliche Entwicklung noch nicht abgeschlossen ist. Ja, also ich beschreibe das ja im Buch, wenn es um diese Folien geht, dann ging es zum Beispiel unter anderem darum, dass wir im Torwarttrainerlehrgang die Entwicklungsstufen präsentiert haben für die Teilnehmenden. Also welche Entwicklungsstufen durchlaufen. Spieler, muss man in dem Moment ja sagen. Wann ist was gefragt? Wann sind die körperlich wie weit? Und ich habe mir das halt angeschaut und dachte mir, das stimmt aber überhaupt nicht für Mädchen. Unsere Pubertät entwickelt sich ganz anders. Und wir haben dann durch die Periode noch mal einen besonderen Einschnitt und wir haben körperlich eben zum Beispiel nicht diese Wachstumsschubprobleme, wo ich so dachte, für uns kann das gar nicht passen. Und da würde ich wirklich sagen, würde ich die Forschung in der Spitze ansetzen und die Erkenntnisse dann zum Beispiel durch die Trainerinnen-Lehrgänge in die Breite bringen. Weil das sind Menschen, die sind hauptberuflich Dachdecker, die können jetzt nicht noch irgendwie 15 Paper lesen in ihrer Freizeit, wie jetzt gerade die Lage ist. Sondern da würde ich mir wünschen, dass das dann vernünftig aufbereitet wird. Vom DFB geht das ja an die Landesverbände und da bringen das dann die Referenten in die untersten Amateurlizenzen. Jeder, der Kreisliga-Trainer sein will, muss eine C-Lizenz machen. Und da kann man sowas super in so einem Theorie-Blog präsentieren. Das ist jetzt im Moment die Lage, wenn ihr eine Frauenmannschaft trainiert, achtet in der Vorbereitung darauf, dass ihr eben, wir haben jetzt keine Erkenntnisse, random Beispiel, dass ihr eben den Lauftest montags macht. Aber wenn dann eben Leute ihre Periode haben, dann lasst die lieber erst freitags laufen. Und die können dann separat aber das und das schon machen. Ja, die können vielleicht den Krafttest besser absolvieren. Dass man einfach solide Daten hat, anstatt dass alle immer raten. Und ehrlicherweise alle durchlaufen dieselben Lehrgänge. Männer wie Frauen. Das heißt, wir haben auch viele Männer, die im Frauenbereich arbeiten. Die haben diese Erkenntnisse hundertprozentig auch nicht. Aber auch die Frauen können nur aus ihrem eigenen Erfahrungsschatz irgendwie arbeiten und haben keine gesicherten Daten an der Hand, wo man sagen kann, so plan ich die Vorbereitung am besten, damit wir nicht nur 14 an Tag 1, sondern damit auch die meisten gesund sind. Damit die meisten eine ganze Saison schaffen. Also in Schweden waren wir damals schon deutlich weiter aufgestellt. Da hatten wir quasi eine hauptamtliche Physiotherapeutin, die die ganze medizinische Abteilung geleitet hat und die auch zum Beispiel Verletzungsprävention im Aufwärmen geleitet hat. Und obwohl wir damals schon auf Kunstrasen da gespielt haben, hatten wir weniger Kreuzbandrisse und weniger Knöchelverletzungen, als ich es in jedem deutschen Club erlebt habe. Und das hat mir einfach auch nochmal gezeigt, wenn man das ganze wissenschaftlich, datenbasiert, medizinisch angeht, dann muss es nicht so sein. Es ist nicht so, als wäre der weibliche Körper nicht gemacht für solche Belastungen und würde automatisch darunter zerbrechen, sondern die Bedingungen haben Einfluss darauf, wie viele Spiele wir pro Saison schaffen. Und alles, was dann da einfach so ausprobiert wird, ist eigentlich fahrlässig und ist einfach wirklich ein Versuch am lebenden Objekt.
Es sind so viele Themen. Wir werden auch nicht mal alle Themen hier ansprechen können in dem Gespräch. Aber gut, eigentlich war es fast zu erwarten. Es ist auch ein bisschen so ein Rasenfunk-Thema. Aber die Leute sollen ja auf jeden Fall eure Bücher lesen. Ich habe sie noch gar nicht namentlich genannt. Also Kathrins Buch, Wir verdienen mehr. Könnt ihr jetzt schon vorbestellen. Links und so weiter natürlich sowieso in den Shownotes. Und Lena's Buch Aufstiegskampf vom Seitenrand in die Primetime. Ich habe es zu kurz in die Kamera gehalten. Da sieht man, dass ich kein Fernsehen mache. Das könnt ihr ab dem 12.4. kaufen. Also jetzt, wenn ihr das hört, dann ist das schon erhältlich. Wird natürlich auch verlinkt in den Shownotes. Lena, ich würde noch ganz gerne mit dir kurz noch über das sprechen, was du dann eben bei deinem Wechsel in den Journalismus erlebt hast. Denn da musste auch wieder einiges zusammenkommen, dass wir dich vor einer Fernsehkamera jetzt regelmäßig zu sehen bekommen. Und wenn man dich aber regelmäßig vor einer Fernsehkamera sieht, dann versteht man das gar nicht, weil du bist da so souverän und schlau und witzig und so weiter und so fort. Ich meine, musst dich jetzt nicht weiter lobhudeln. Alle wissen, dass ich immer auch sehr froh bin, wenn du im Rasenfunk bist. Und trotzdem hat es eben doch einige Umwege gebraucht, um dorthin zu kommen. Wie viel von diesen Umwegen würdest du denn sagen, kommt auch daher, dass du eine Frau bist? Denn jeder, der es irgendwie geschafft hat in eine solche Position, der würde von sich sagen, ja, da musste da, das musste und der musste auf mich aufmerksam werden. Aber was glaubst du, wie viel Prozent oder ich weiß nicht, wie man es ausdrücken kann, kamen daher, dass du eben in einer Männerdomäne als Frau deinen Weg gegangen bist?
Ich glaube, Frauen in der Gesellschaft und ich glaube, in sehr, sehr vielen gesellschaftlichen Bereichen starten erstmal im Minus, während Männer in jedem gesellschaftlichen Bereich erstmal im Plus starten. Und bis du dich aus diesem Minusbereich zumindest mal in diese Nullzone katapultierst, dauert es als Frau sehr, sehr lange und braucht sehr, sehr viel Mut und auch sehr, sehr viel Stärke. Und du brauchst sehr viel Resilienz. Und ich glaube, bei mir speziell war das Ding, dass es ja Frauen im Sport und in diesem Bereich gab und zwar auch vor der Kamera, aber es gab eben immer nur eine gewisse Art der Frau vor der Kamera. Und ich glaube auch, dass es nach wie vor so ist, dass es zwar Frauen in der ersten Reihe in diesem Männer dominierten Habitat gibt, aber sie dürfen nur in einer gewissen Form existieren. Und so wie ich war und so wie ich bin, und mein damaliger Sportchef hat es mit den Beschreibungen zu laut und zu bunt auf den Punkt gebracht, ist es schwer, in diesem Bereich in der ersten Reihe zu stehen, weil das ist nicht für Frauen vorhergesehen, dass sie sich Raum nehmen, dass sie vielleicht selbstbewusst sind, dass sie vielleicht humorvoll sind, dass sie meinungsstark sind, dass sie präsent sind. Und das, was bei Frauen zu viel ist, ist bei Männern dann genau richtig. Anstatt dann als Frau die Zuschreibungen, die du zu hören bekommst, ja du bist manchmal zu cool, höre ich bis heute noch, du bist zu selbstbewusst. Das ist dann bei Männern halt, du bist schlagfertig und du bist eloquent. Und das ist eben etwas, wo ich sage, wenn wir echte Diversität wollen, wenn wir echten Wandel wollen in dieser Gesellschaft, dann muss es auch endlich mehr Raum für Individualität von Frauen geben. Weil du nur dann auch in unterschiedliche Lebensrealitäten reinwirken kannst, die eventuell normalerweise nicht in der ersten Reihe stehen. Und ich glaube, das ist ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Aspekt, warum ich auch meine Geschichte erzähle. Weil ich endlich in andere Lebensrealitäten rein möchte. Weil ich zeigen möchte, dass es auch als angeblich zu laut und zu bunt durchaus am Ende auch erfolgreich sein kann. Und dass man als Frau auch unangepasst sein darf. Und wir neigen dazu, überangepasst zu sein, um überhaupt Platz in dieser Gesellschaft zu haben. Also ich glaube, dafür braucht es Geschichten, die zeigen, dass es anders geht. Und ich möchte, dass Frauen endlich ihre Geschichte erzählen. Und ich würde sogar so weit gehen, dass ich mir nicht nur mehr Diversität hinsichtlich des Geschlechtes wünschen würde, sondern auch hinsichtlich der wirklichen Lebensrealitäten. Und das heißt auch, dass Männer viel diverser sein sollten in diesem Bereich. Dass da nicht nur dunke blaue Anzüge mit weißes Nikan stehen, sondern dass da dicke, dünne Menschen, schwarze, weiße Menschen, arme, reiche Menschen, links und konservative Menschen stattfinden dürfen. Und ich glaube, dafür brauchen wir viel mehr Geschichten. Und ich befinde mich in einem so elitären Umfeld mittlerweile. Und das beschreibe ich ja auch in meinem Buch, dass ich durchaus damit sehr, sehr fremde, weil ich mich überhaupt gar nicht zugehörig fühle. Und das bedeutet eben auch, weil da ich nicht nur als Frau mich oftmals alleine fühle, sondern auch als die Art von Frau, die ich darstelle, als queere Person, die aus einem bildungsfernen Haushalt auf dem Dorf groß geworden ist, die nicht Akademiker-Eltern hatte, die nicht irgendwen kannte, der in irgendeiner Sport-Redaktion gearbeitet hat, die ihr erstes Geld an der Rewe-Kasse verdient hat, die danach bei der Deutschen Post Briefe sortiert hat, während alle anderen Praktika beim Kicker gemacht haben. Und all diese Geschichten, die finden einfach nicht statt. Und die sind nicht sichtbar. Und ich glaube, wenn du wirklich Vorbild sein möchtest, dann musst du endlich deine Geschichte erzählen, die zeigt, dass es auch andere Geschichten gibt in dieser ersten Reihe. Und das war so mein Weg in diesem sportjournalistischen Bereich, der sehr elitär ist und wo ich oftmals und auch nach wie vor noch Schwierigkeiten habe, mich richtig wohlzufühlen. Und ich glaube, da muss man mutig genug sein, damit andere Frauen oder andere Menschen sich angesprochen fühlen und sehen, ach krass, guck mal, das war Lena's Weg und der hat irgendwie sehr viel auch mit meinem zu tun. Oder ich habe Anknüpfungspunkte. Und wir sehen ja immer nur die Spitze des Eisbergs und wir sehen gar nicht, was da drunter ist. Und ich glaube, das hilft für mehr Menschen wirklich Vorbild zu sein und die auch ihren Weg gehen wollen, die vielleicht auch nicht so gute Startvoraussetzungen hatten. Und nur dann können wir wirklich Diversität in dieser Gesellschaft abbilden, ohne dass wir die ganze Zeit ritualisiert über so Themen wie Diversität und Vielfalt sprechen. Einmal im Jahr, irgendwann, an einem Diversitätstag. Sondern das müssen wir auf diese Gefühlsebene bringen. Und dafür braucht es Geschichten und dafür braucht es auch Emotionen. Und ich glaube, während du Kathrin in deinem Buch viel über Daten und so sprichst, ist bei mir, also ich mache mich halt wirklich nackig so. Also all das, was ich bin, ist in diesem Buch. Und ich glaube, das brauche ich, um echten Wandel zu vollziehen. Und dafür musst du dich nackig machen, dafür musst du dich demaskieren. Und ich würde nicht nur sagen, dass dieses Buch junge Frauen lesen sollen, sondern das Buch sollen bitte auch alte weiße Männer lesen. Weil ich glaube, das hilft, um empathisch zu werden. Das hilft, um Wohlwollen zu haben für andere Geschichten. Und ja, ich glaube, so würde ich so ein bisschen meinen Weg dann auch in diesem Sportfernsehen beschreiben. Er ist eine bumpy road gewesen und er ist es nach wie vor. Und ich glaube trotzdem, dass es wichtig ist, dass ich da meinen Platz habe und ich würde dazu, also ich hoffe, dass ich dadurch ganz viele andere Menschen animiere, ja, ihren Raum in dieser Gesellschaft wahrzunehmen, obwohl er vielleicht für sie nicht vorhergesehen war.
Wenn ich eine kurze Sache ergänzen darf, weil das ist so absurd, dass dir gesagt wurde, du seist zu cool, zu schlagfertig, würdest du dem Experten zu wenig Raum geben. Eine Freundin von mir hatte sich beworben bei Sky für den Ricardo-Basile-Job, also als es diesen Job noch gab, also der Social-Media-Beauftragte der Konferenz, der dann eben die Instagram-Postings vorschlägt, und hat ihn nicht bekommen mit dem Argument, ja, wir trauen dir nicht zu, dass du Lothar Matthäus auch mal eine schlagkräftige Antwort gibst. Und ich kenne diese Frau sehr gut und ich kann euch sagen, also wenn es woran überhaupt nicht mangelt, dann an Schlagkraft, an Witz und an Eloquenz. Das war einfach nur ein vorgeschobenes Argument. Ich wollte das einfach nur noch daneben stellen. Und gleichzeitig glaube ich, dass da eben auch jetzt viel bei Kathrin noch mal angedockt hat, obwohl euer Weg sich dann so getrennt hat. Ich habe dich öfter nicken sehen, und es ist auch so interessant, wie sich eure Bücher ergänzen. Also liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr müsst wirklich bitte beide lesen, weil es greift ineinander und man bekommt auch einfach so viele Argumente, wenn man Kathrins Buch liest, bei dem man in Zukunft immer sagen kann, ja, nee, stimmt nicht. Einfach jetzt mal dieses Totschlagargument, das lassen wir hier nicht gelten. Kathrin, ich vermute, bei dir sind jetzt auch schon wieder eigene Parallelen aufgefallen, bei dem, was Lena gesagt hat.
Ja, total. Und wo ich wirklich anknüpfen kann, ist auch dieser Punkt, unsere Geschichten müssen halt erzählt werden. Und dafür muss man irgendwo anfangen. Und ich habe zwar diese Daten und Statistiken gesammelt, um ein paar dieser Scheinargumente mal, ein für alle mal ad acta zu legen. Aber was ich ja auch mache, ist trotzdem meine Geschichte erzählen. Ich verknüpfe diese Daten einfach als Beweis, dass das, was mir passiert ist, nicht nur durch Zufall mir passiert ist, weil ich ein bestimmtes Alter habe oder in einem bestimmten Verein gespielt habe, sondern dass das der Beleg dafür ist, dass es allen passiert ist, über alle Jahrzehnte und immer gleich ungerecht und gleich sinnlos war. Ja, also ich habe einfach während meiner Karriere, ich habe ja dann nun mal einen Sprung auch in diesen Leistungsfußball geschafft, einfach festgestellt, dass so viele Menschen eine Vorstellung von meinem Beruf haben, eine Meinung zu meinem Sport haben, aber ehrlicherweise wirklich keine Ahnung haben, keine Ahnung, wie der Alltag als Fußballspielerin in Deutschland aussieht, wie der Weg in den Leistungsfußball aussieht, wie es ist, mit der Nationalmannschaft vier Wochen in Thailand zu sein mit 17, ohne eine Lehrkraft dabei zu haben. Ich hatte nicht mal einen Torwarttrainer in der Jugendnationalmannschaft oder Torwarttrainerin. Ja, und nochmal, wir reden nicht über 1982. Das war 2004. Ja, also wir wurden quasi mit dem Besten, als Beste des Jahrgangs zu einem internationalen Turnier geschickt. Und ich habe da vier Wochen mich mit der anderen gegenseitig wagen geschossen. Ich hätte ehrlicherweise zu Hause mehr gelernt. Ja, weil im Verein hatte ich wenigstens einen Torwarttrainer. Das sind so Beispiele, an denen ich einfach klarmachen will. Das, was ihr denkt, über uns zu wissen, wisst ihr einfach nicht. Ja, und ich bin trotzdem nur eine Biografie von vielen. Da sind wir wieder bei Vielfalt. Es gibt viel mehr noch zu erzählen, auch viel schwierigere Wege noch. Aber ich habe dann ab einem gewissen Punkt gedacht, egal, ich fange jetzt einfach mal an. Ja, ich fange jetzt einfach mal an, aus meiner Generation, aus meinen Vereinen zu berichten, weil ich weiß, für wie viele das schon repräsentativ ist. Und weil auch durch die Benachteiligung unsere Geschichten überall fehlen. Es gibt nicht die großen Bundesliga-Galas für die Frauenbundesliga oder die Ehrungen, wenn eine von unseren Nationalspielerinnen mal 60 wird oder die großen historischen Rückblicke. Es gibt ganz wenig Spielerinnenbiografien, ganz wenig Trainerinnenbiografien. Und ich dachte mir, wir müssen einfach viel mehr von diesen Geschichten erzählen, damit wir greifbarer werden, damit wir diese Emotionen wecken können. Die Lena auch gesagt hat, damit Menschen sich auch mit uns identifizieren können, aber auch damit sie wirklich eine realistischere Vorstellung davon kriegen, was für Hürden und Schwierigkeiten Mädchen und Frauen überwinden müssen, wenn sie den Fußball lieben, wenn sie Fußball spielen möchten und wenn sie im Fußball arbeiten möchten. Und die Hürden bestehen eben größtenteils immer noch. Ja, und ich habe keine Lust mehr. Ich höre seit 30 Jahren dieselben Argumente, dieselben dummen Sprüche. Ich habe keine Lust mehr, unter jedem YouTube-Highlight-Video zu lesen. Ja, und jetzt wollen die auch noch gleich viel Geld, nur wenn mal irgendwie ein Torwartfehler passiert ist. Ja, oder jetzt unter dem Nations League-Zusammenschnitt habe ich bei YouTube gelesen, auf jede von euch wartet irgendwo eine einsame Küche. Und da denke ich mir, so weit sind wir einfach noch nicht gekommen. Wir können gerne so tun in unserer linken Medienwabbel, ja, wo wir alle super divers sind und offen und so. Der breiten Fußball ist nicht so, glaubt mir. Ich war im November noch bei einer Trainerfortbildung, weil ich meine Lizenz verlängern musste. Da kommen immer noch dieselben Fragen. Da ist auch so viel Unwissenheit. Ganz viel Unwissenheit. Neben den Vorbehalten haben auch ganz viele einfach wirklich keine Ahnung. Und deswegen dachte ich, ich pack einfach alles, was ich weiß und was ich irgendwie belegen kann in ein großes Buch. Dann können alle mal nachblättern. Ich stehe für alle Rückfragen offen, aber wir brauchen so viele mehr Geschichten in dieser Öffentlichkeit. So viele Beispiele, so viele konkrete Wege, wie eben der von Lena und mir, an dem Menschen sehen können, eben wie hart es ist, aber auch wie interessant wir einfach sind, ist ja einfach so, wie du schon gesagt hast, die geileren Geschichten gibt es im Frauenfußball zu erzählen. Und da sind noch ganz viele unbekannt.
Und ich glaube auch schon, dass wir nicht nur dieses apokalyptische Narrativ bedienen, dass alles ganz, ganz schlimm ist. Ja. Und also, ich glaube schon, dass es auch wichtig ist, dass Geschichten erzählt werden, damit gesehen wird, dass auch wirklich Frauen in diesem Bereich da sind. Weil oftmals ist das ja auch so, dass man dann vielleicht als junges Mädchen denkt oder als junge Frau, boah, will ich überhaupt in diesem Bereich? Weil das ist ja alles so schrecklich und das ist ja so männerdominiert. Und dann, boah, nee, weiß ich gar nicht. Weil, wie soll ich mich denn da wohlfühlen? Und das hat ja auch eine total abschreckende Wirkung. Und ich glaube, wenn wir anfangen, die Geschichten, die es gibt, sichtbarer werden zu lassen und uns auch als Persönlichkeiten sichtbarer werden zu lassen, dann checkt man auch, oh Gott, da gibt es ja aber Frauen. Und da gibt es ja sogar tolle Frauen, die irgendwie aufgeklärt sind, die vielleicht die gleichen Themen haben wie ich. Und ich glaube, das schafft natürlich auch einen Anreiz für andere Frauen, doch in diesen Bereich zu gehen. Und ich glaube schon, dass es wichtig ist, dass wir das so ein bisschen mit Frauen, die schon durchaus in diesem Bereich tätig sind, aufweichen, dass sie mehr in die erste Reihe kommen. Und damit wir nicht nur diese böse Erzählung bedienen, da sind nur böse Männer. Ich glaube schon, dass ich mir da auch wünschen würde, dass die Frauen dies gibt, sich mehr trauen, ein bisschen mehr zu erzählen, damit dann auch wir am Ende nicht nur eine, sondern viele sind. Und ich glaube schon, dass wir uns da ein bisschen mehr in den Vordergrund stellen müssen und zeigen müssen, weil es gibt die Frauen in diesem Bereich. Und zwar ziemlich tolle, nur sie haben nicht immer die Strahlkraft und sie haben nicht immer das Spotlight. Und ich glaube, das sollte sich ändern. Und damit schaffen wir dann auch Anreize, dass es mehr werden.
Absolut. Und ich meine, wir müssen auch da, um nicht zu sehr da auch in Rollendenken zu verfallen, natürlich sagen, ich hatte unfassbar viele hilfreiche Männer auf meinem Weg im Fußballgeschäft. Und ich hatte auch Frauen, die nicht besonders hilfreich waren. Es ist nicht immer eine Geschlechterfrage, wie feministisch man zum Beispiel denkt oder wie innovativ oder progressiv man auch handelt. Da sind es meiner Meinung nach bleiben auch viele tolle Männer im Fußball, so wie er jetzt ist auf der Strecke, weil er eben nicht passt, weil eben die Diversität fehlt, wie du gesagt hast Lena, weil auch Räume für diese Männer fehlen, sich zu öffnen, sie selbst zu sein und Spotlight zu nehmen. Wir haben ja immer wieder dann das Beispiel auch der homosexuellen Fußballspieler zum Beispiel, die es ja offiziell immer noch nicht geben darf. Ja, also auch da bietet der Fußball, so wie er jetzt ist, nicht genug Raum für Vielfalt. Und die definitiv da ist, aber die noch nicht sichtbar ist. Und ich glaube, die hoffnungsvolle Note, auf die wir uns ja auch beide einigen können, ist, es war ein steiniger Weg, aber es war definitiv alles wert, so wie es gelaufen ist. Ich würde nichts anders machen. Ich habe mich einen Tag bereut, dass ich Fußballspielerin geworden bin. Es war mein absoluter Traumberuf. Ich habe es geliebt. An den Tagen, wo ich sehr schlimme Schmerzen hatte, vielleicht nicht, aber am nächsten Morgen schon wieder, wenn die Reha angefangen hat und ich wusste, jetzt geht es wieder bergauf und bald kann ich wieder auf dem Platz stehen. Ich liebte den Fußball bis heute ab, ich habe das Trainerinnen-Dasein geliebt. Jetzt bin ich ja gerade auch in Elternzeit. Auch da muss ich fairerweise sagen, weiß ich nicht, wie gut ich zurückkommen kann als Mutter im Fußball. Das wird sich zeigen müssen. Auch da sind die Strukturen noch relativ unbekannt. Aber das Spiel an sich hat alles erfüllt, was ich mir davon erhofft habe und mehr. Ich habe keinen Tag bereut, dass ich das alles so gemacht habe. Ich würde mir einfach nur wünschen, dass die Frauen, die nach mir kommen, es ein Stück weit leichter haben und sich zumindest mit manchen Problemen, die man vermeiden kann, nicht mehr rumschlagen müssen.
Dann landen wir doch am Schluss dieser Sendung wieder bei dem, mit dem wir angefangen haben. Die Liebe zum Fußball, das ist es eben. Das ist das, was bleibt. Und vielleicht kann ich noch die eine Anmerkung dazu machen. Ich bekomme ja sehr viele Bücher auch einfach zugeschickt und gucke dann auch immer mal wieder rein. Das heißt, ich habe schon viele Biografien gelesen. Und ein großer Unterschied, den es gibt zwischen Biografien oder Autobiografien von Männern hin zu Autobiografien von Frauen, ist, Männer kommen immer am Ende in ihrem Schlusskapitel dazu. Ich bin froh, dass ich mich durchgeboxt habe und es war nicht immer alles ganz leicht, aber der Fußball hat mir so viel gegeben. Also bei dem, bei dem ihr jetzt auch gerade gelandet seid, aber bei den Frauen eigentlich, ich würde fast jetzt sagen, in jeder Autobiografie, die ich da gelesen habe, kommt man am Ende auch irgendwann immer an einen Punkt, ich würde gern meinem früheren Ich sagen, du bist okay so wie du bist. Mach das einfach genauso weiter. Und das finde ich total interessant, dass dieser Zusatz bei Frauen da ist und wir wissen warum, weil wir haben die Gründe dafür, darüber haben wir jetzt gerade gesprochen und es gibt noch tausend weitere und bei Männern fehlt das dann aber eben doch. Deswegen ist das wäre so der Versuch eines Fazits dieser Sendung. Ihr zwei, ich möchte mich ganz, ganz herzlich bei euch bedanken. Ich möchte noch mal sagen, bitte lest die beiden Bücher Aufstiegskampf von Lena Cassel und Wir verdienen mehr von Kathrin Längert. Es wird alles verlinkt. Man kann euch auch einladen und interviewen und auch da wird alles in den Shownotes verlinkt werden. Und ich wünsche euch nur den allergrößten Erfolg mit den beiden Büchern, die ihr da geschrieben habt und möchte euch auch stellvertretend für alle, die das lesen, danken für den Mut und die Arbeit, die ihr da reingesteckt habt, denn ein Buch zu schreiben, meine Güter. Also ihr habt so einiges durchgemacht in euren Karrieren, aber ja, ich sehe es. Man sieht es in beiden Gesichtern, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wenn ihr es gerade nicht sehen könnt.
Auch noch in deinem Gesicht, lieber Max. Ich kann nämlich an den Prozess bei dir ja auch noch dran erinnern.
Also deswegen wirklich beeindruckend, dass ihr durchgezogen habt. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank für die Zeit, die ihr euch genommen habt für den Rasenfunk. Danke Lena, danke Kathrin.
Danke dir, Max.
Vielen Dank, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, mit uns zu sprechen.
Also das ist wirklich das Allermindeste. Und ich danke natürlich am Schluss auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn ihr wisst ja, alles hier im Rasenfunk, auch diese Sendung ist nur möglich, da ihr den Rasenfunk möglich macht. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Auch deswegen müssen wir nicht auf Reichweite gucken bei unseren Sendungen z.B. und können einfach das machen, was wir wichtig finden. Auf rasenfunk.de, da erfahrt ihr, wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt. Geht auf jedem Weg, den man sich so vorstellen kann. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Kreisliga-Pellet, bei Kalle Pflipsen, bei Fred Eriksson, bei Jororo, bei Kette, bei Alex aus Gotha und bei Anna und Jochen. Vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank für eure Unterstützung. Wir freuen uns über Feedback auf diese Folge. Unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de findet ihr ein sehr schönes Forum, in dem man sich gut austauschen kann, lest die beiden Bücher von Lena und Kathrin. Ich möchte das als letztes Mal nochmal mitgeben und bleib dem Rasenfunk auch gerne gewogen. Wir haben auch andere Feeds, die ihr gerne abonnieren könnt. Wir sprechen über die Bundesliga der Frauen, die Bundesliga der Männer, in der Ligatur über den zweiten Männerliga-Fußball und im Nationalteams-Feed über alle deutschen Nationalteams. In diesem Sinne macht's gut.
Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank.